over this past weekend there's been some
very serious and extreme military
conflict erupting in the Middle East but
to put it a bit more simply Hamas
invaded into Israel into Israel and
started killing civilians over 5,000
Rockets were fired targeting civilian
areas and it's pretty extreme in
response to this Israel has declared a
full Siege on Gaza and now we're
watching buildings being flattened and
of course you've got people on the left
defending Palestine and then you
actually have establishment more
establishment Democrat uh types
criticizing the far- left and actually
advocating for more Aid and uh in
defense of Israel with many
conservatives split as well
interestingly this uh this issue has has
divided everybody quite a bit with many
on the right under Trump being either
very defensive of Israel or very anti
anti- intervention it gets interesting
when you look at exactly what went down
and the big news that's happening now so
oh boy do we have a lot to talk about
here there are hostages being murdered
right now by Hamas there are threats to
execute more hostages as Israel
retaliates and fires into Gaza and
there's reports that the hostages may
contain American citizens and reports
that 11 Americans have already died
we're going to talk about all that but
then there's the political ramifications
as well additionally RFK Jr announced
today that he will be running as an
independent I believe based on
everything we've seen there's good
reason to believe this will hurt
Democrats especially considering rfk's
speech was very much so is very woke
celebrating indigenous people's day
which is uh apparently today I guess
it's Christopher Columbus Day and it's a
bank holiday but we're going to get into
all that before we get started today my
friends head over to safeand ready
meals.com safe and ready meals.com is
where you can get Emergency Food
Supplies that last up to 25 years head
over there now stays fresh up 25 years
top quality freeze dried foods this
stuff here's how it works you get a
bunch of little these little bags you
pour H water in it it's that simple now
I don't normally and I I typically don't
shout out safe and ready meals but I
think considering what we're seeing
right now a lot of people have in their
minds being prepared I love that word is
uh uh it's serious look I don't know
where this goes we've got war in Eastern
Europe we now have one of the most
serious escalations happening in the
Middle East all I can tell you right now
is sometimes it rains right when you're
when you're going to website like safe
Andre meals.com to buy Emergency Food
Supplies it's not just about the
apocalypse or anything like that that's
extreme and we don't know what's what's
what's going to happen but sometimes it
rains sometimes there floods and you
never know when you're going to need
food you got a first aid kit right well
you should have some food and supplies
so shout outs uh safe and ready
meals.com supporting the show uh I
haven't shouted them out in a very very
long time but I think considering
everything we're seeing I really just
want you all to be self-sufficient and
uh when you buy from safe and ready
meals.com you're supporting the show so
check that out also check out Cas
brew.com we've got the limited edition
rise with Roberto Jr I'm sorry rise with
Roberto Jr coming out for This Halloween
not available just yet and head over to
timcast.net
hi Tim it's uh James Bacon former
Special Assistant to president Trump and
director of operations for presidential
Personnel in the Trump White House happy
to be here right on thanks for coming we
got Hannah clir hanging out yeah hi I'm
Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net
bet David Matt Gates James O'Keefe Tim
Luke and I were all there on St I mean
Hannah clir you were there too the whole
gang was there it was great to see you
guys before the show uh some of you guys
after the show and um today I did
something i' i' never done before I
prayed to Jesus I've never done this
before I've always prayed to God so I
decided to communicate with Jesus
directly and I I said please help me and
he said he told me to tell them so I'm
telling you I did it well there you go
yeah thanks thank you it was it was it
was still kind of hazy like you know
anyway let's get in you want to get
let's get down with the show Serge talk
to me yo uh yeah pleasure being in Miami
it was fun um funny how the world kind
of went to hell when we were gone but
yeah I'm surge.com let's get ready
here's a story from the Wall Street
Journal the latest I'm sure many of you
have heard about what's been going on
between Israel and Palestine Hamas
threatens to execute Israelis in
response to bombing of Gaza we have an
image here shocking image flames and
smoke billow during Israeli strikes in
Gaza on Monday these photos are
absolutely crazy there's videos now
emerging from Gaza as Israel retaliates
Over The Killing of civilians I believe
it is estimated at 900 plus dead the
number is probably higher now think
it's, 1,100 I i' I'd seen something
similar so of course there's going to be
retaliation the wal joural says Hamas on
Monday threatened to execute Israeli
hostages if Israel continues to bombard
civilian homes in Gaza without warning
from this hour on WE announced that any
targeting of Civilian homes that
advanced warning will be met regrettably
with the execution of one of the enemy
civilian hostages we hold and we'll be
forced to broadcast broadcast this says
Abu obida the spokesman for hamas's
military Wing alqassam brigades in Rim
marks broadcast on pan Arab Channel Al
jazer the enemy does not understand the
language of humanity and morals and we
will address him in the language he
knows we hold the occupation responsible
for this decision in front of the world
I'm sorry I mean it's plain as day these
are not Secrets this is not someone uh
this is not a fake video produc this a a
human being saying yes we we stormed
into the civilian areas kidnapped and
and and and captured civilians that we
consider enemies and that they intend
that they're now saying they intend to
kill okay this argument about Freedom
Fighters or whatever not that doesn't
fly I I I'm not going to bite you want
to come at me and talk about war and
history and Israel and occupation like
let's have a conversation we can talk
about the West Bank we can talk about uh
uh people going to the West Bank and
bulldozing homes or or or seizing
property all of that stuff we can have a
conversation but this right here there's
zero justification there are people
right now in New York I shouldn't say
right now but probably right now over
this past weekend celebrating the
killing of
civilians so what is this where where do
we go from here this is a war of
colonization and it's the first time
we've ever seen it on TV in real time
it's happened for for the history of
mankind but you only hear like they went
in and they marauded 18 border towns and
then they were there and they destroyed
the crops and then they came back but
you don't hear you didn't see them
murdering the people raping the
women uh kidnapping the children to
raise as their own like you don't see
that and now we see it and this is what
it looks like yeah it's a strange part
of Modern Warfare how quickly we can see
what's going on on the ground especially
given the wide access of the internet I
mean there are a number of people that I
would be interested to hear their take
the Hadid sisters are obviously uh not
what I would call political influencers
but they have been very vocally Pro
Palestine given their Heritage um it's
just um it's been a crazy weekend it's
been a lot of um sort of a deluse of
information
yeah I don't know what's real and what's
not that's part of why this is this is a
this is an opportunity to speak
scientifically on on what I've seen over
the weekend I suppose I what I find
really fascinating about this is that
you have far
leftists and what do you what do you
call what do you call this um I don't
even know what you'd call the the
faction of anti-Semitic or anti-israel
I'm not saying literally the same thing
there's people who hate Jewish people
people who hate Israel or let's let's
try and and T it down as much as
possible there are people who reject the
idea of Israel who are considered who
are more Nationalist and and there are
white nationalists they're
aligned in this regard with the far-left
completely not not in the sense of like
Pro Palestine but in opposition to
Israel as a state and it's just a very
very weird circumstance to see prominent
conservatives now completely in
agreement with the Democrats
surprisingly it's like all of a sudden
like whoa It's just Ming and mashing
everything
up yeah it is I mean I think think it's
uh reflective of a lot of stuff that's
going on in our country where we have
been used to uh certain political
parties claiming certain certain values
and ultimately um especially in
complicated nuanced situations people
you wouldn't expect to agree actually
have common ground when I think of
far-left I think of people that support
Palestine and that's what I've I've
always kind of ass and it may not be
true but the people on the far left are
like no Israel is an invading Force we
need to but then the the Biden
administrations engaged with the
far-left had this these people and this
is maybe I'm just misreading the
situation through the media I've been
I've been watching but and now Biden
sent an aircraft carrier over there to
support Israel but his constituency is
like the left and they don't want they
support Palestine and it's a very broad
General assumption but that's a that's a
conflict of interest um and maybe that's
a good thing well I think there's no
room for the Nuance take here which is
obviously Israel has a right to respond
and fight Hamas because they were
attacked in a vicious terrorist attack
but that we should be focused on making
sure this thing doesn't break out into
World War I that is what the US's
interest is here you know I'm not you're
right in essence but considering who's
in charge of this country I'm not so
sure their interests align with what
you're describing I think a lot of these
companies have a vested interest in
World War II and then there's a big
question about what constitutes World
War II with the start of the of the uh
with the Russian invasion of Ukraine
or you can even go back to say like the
US backed ousting of yanukovich in
Ukraine whatever you I mean these things
can all be reduced you can go way back
in time but with the conflict the hot
conflict you've got prominent people in
Europe saying this is World War III
already now you add into the mix what
will likely be the most dramatic and
egregious military escalation from
Israel into Gaza that we've ever seen
and may result in the end of Gaza I mean
the the videos that are coming out of
buildings being leveled
it's it's brutal they're saying this is
our
911 this could be World War II I mean
look I know everybody's always like oh
oh you're being sensationalist by saying
World War II I will just say this for
all I know tomorrow everybody stops
there's a there's tears some you know
profit emerges who knows and everyone
stops fighting and they're like I can't
believe we fought and then they all hug
and it's like rainbows okay for all for
all we know that happens even though the
conflict's been going on for Generations
if not Millennia maybe but if China
invades Taiwan W and sees and tries to
take it right now then I think it's fair
to say like objectively okay World War
II we've got these massive superpower
involved hot conflicts popping up all
over the globe and even then maybe it's
still Fair it's still fair that that
there would be some argument against it
no maybe it's just regional conflict
right if this does devolve into the US
mobilizing Russia mobilizing China
mobilizing into an actual easily
discernable World War III with front
with a front line Western Front they
will look back historically and this
will be a part of that war right so when
when when France Ferdinand died no one
said that's it World War I just start
World War I's on everybody we postdated
it we said oh that was the start exactly
I kind of get the vibe that it was 911
is what is what C catapulted us into the
age of world
chaos I don't know uh look there's been
there's been there was Desert Storm
there there's a whole bunch of conflicts
between the US and and and other
countries and it never ended I mean
after the cold during the Cold War we
had a whole bunch of wars and conflict
it's not stopped there was a period
where it was a little quieter but there
was still Afghanistan and Iraq and one
World War I and two was like the same
War there's that interwar period where
Germany was just Ste seething because
half the or part of the country had been
Stripped Away and given to Poland and
those native Germans that were now under
the control the polls were being
executed and genocided and the Germans
were like you know cast his belly for
war we need to take our land back and it
there's just like one big war with like
10 years of like quiet time yeah I mean
that's probably true of all conflict in
world history of all time right like we
say a war ends but does it really
because the Fallout is what sets up the
next one I mean that's going to be true
obvious it's true now this how we got
here and it's also will be true forever
right we I I love the idea that we'd
live in peace But ultimately someone is
a loser when you live in peace there's
always going to be tension there's the
one of the arguments they're putting
forward right now is that 75 years ago
Israel sees uh Israeli Israeli militants
and militias seized land from
Palestinians it's like okay I get it you
know people were kicked out of their
home 75 years ago I don't see how that
justifies kidnapping and murdering
Germans you know like that there's that
video going around that tattoo artist
who was dancing at the festival and
there are people in New York celebrating
that hipsters at a festival got taken
and the guy laughs and says I'm sure
they're doing fine now he knows they
were all murdered they were all murdered
they're they're dead bodies paraded
around dude you want to talk about war
and conflict fine but like if if they
were really trying to say like take back
their homes or tear down the fences of
an open air prison which b means make
all these arguments I don't see how
they're like we we've escaped the prison
quick go kill civilians like imagine
there's a dude who claims he was
wrongfully jailed and he's in prison and
he's like I shouldn't be here I'm
innocent I was forced in here by
corruption and tyranny I'm a political
prisoner and then he breaks out and then
he runs straight for some 20-year-old
woman and just beats her to death you'd
be like dude you should have been in
prison I think that a lot the majority
probably a grand majority of the people
in Palestine and in in Gaza whatever you
want to call it they they call some
people call it Gaza some people call it
Palestine whatever Gaza is the strip
left over of Palestine basically and the
West Bank as well as Palestine so
they're not violent they're just stuck
and and they're trying to live but then
there's milit very angry small group of
militant activists Hamas and others you
know that are willing to kill and are
are creating a situation where these
civilians are now in the line of fire
it's true for a lot of civilians there
are there are a lot of programs that try
to uh bring Aid to to the GSA strip I
remember uh it's a really really crazy
thing when I went to Israel and I was in
Tel Aviv and uh I I know people who were
involved in skateboard projects in Gaza
and people skate in G in Gaza and uh I'm
talking to this Israeli uh person about
you know like it was really cool to see
in the United States a Palestinian from
Gaza who made it to the US and was
skateboarding with an Israeli and
they're like high-fiving and fist
bumping being like you know we could if
only we could find this kind of peace
and then the Israeli guy goes no they
don't skateboard and I was like what yes
they do there's like skate parks in G no
there's not and I was like yeah there is
Google it right now I'll pull the video
up for you like I'm just like do you
genuinely think that's not true like and
I think the issue is that for a lot of
these more um liberal-minded like this
this uh this German citizen who was who
was reportedly killed was a a German
National but also dual citizen Israeli
conscience is objector and pacifist and
it's these people who are raised in this
um left liberal leftist mindset liberal
mindset of world peace and perhaps they
saw one of these videos of this dude
from Palestine fist bumping a guy from
Israel of course Palestinians got really
mad about that but the dudes in America
he like I just want to escape man leave
me alone like they don't care about
anything else and uh and I've also heard
the inverse too but they see stories
like this and like we can't have peace
and then like I'll say it again like
call it an open air prison that's fine I
got no aru like let's have an argument
we'll talk about it whatever you can
call what you want but if you're going
to make the argument that they're trying
to break free
then they just run out and start killing
people and the woman who got killed was
this pacifist it's like well I was a
cold hard lesson in gun control and
peace when there are people who believe
that you as a civilian and a tourist are
an evil per evil that needs to be purged
there's no negotiating somebody dancing
to music well we could we can argue
about like uh LW and lascivious behavior
and stuff and like the the de Evolution
or the degradation of society and stuff
but come on man like what's the
ification for running into a music
festival and just gunning people down
because in their mind it doesn't matter
who you are you're all evil so it's like
how how are you supposed to have what's
Justice in this situation if these
people in New York are chanting from The
River To The Sea they're talking about
genocide they're talking about Mass
execution dude I'll say it again you
want to talk about 1948 you want to talk
about the British occupied Palestine and
all of that stuff let's have a
conversation but you ain't getting
anything from me when you are literally
singing songs about Mass executing all
the civilians live there yeah it was
1918 I think when the British mandate
for Palestine and okay I'm not exactly
sure what year I think there was
something called the Bal for Declaration
was signed and what happened was during
World War I the the British and the
French were like we cannot win we're
going to lose the Ottoman Empire is
annihilating us the Germans the
austrians they're too powerful so they
made a deal with the Ottomans and they
were like we will give actually let no
let me let me fix that they made a deal
with the Arabs not the Ottomans they
made a deal with the Arabs the Arabs
were also with Germans and the austrians
so the the British and the French made
deal with the Arabs and they said if you
help us win if you turn on the Ottoman
Empire we'll give you this area which is
now Israel we'll give this to you Arabs
so the Arabs said okay so they turned on
the Ottomans and then we they won we won
the war and then they went back on their
offer and they said no we're going to
keep that area for oursel and they set
up the British mandate for Palestine and
occupied it and ever since that's like
the Inception point of when the Arabs
are like you you promised us our land
back like you you were we helped you we
died for you and and now you took it and
now you're there and and that was it it
that's where it began and then there's
something something called the Sykes
Pico agreement where I think Israel was
officially formed I don't want to speak
too much on this but there's something
called the Sykes Pico agreement which is
worth looking into too this is one of
the reasons why I'm like very anti-
intervention I never say I'm like
absolutely anti- intervention because
sometimes I recognize like not
everything's absolute but the problem is
you've got a lot of people who don't
know enough about any of this and it's
so fervent and insane the people being
like Israel has a right blah blah blah
and you know whatever and I'm like bro
I'm sitting here watching people kill
kill civilians like hey don't kill
civilians and then people are still mad
it's crazy like the the the the
pro-israel side is saying like they're
justified in everything they're doing
and whatever uh in retaliation and then
the prop Palestine side are are saying
that they're justified in in in you know
pushing out these these occupiers and
I'm like bro it's like a 20-year-old
woman at a music festival got killed not
the only one and of course I understand
there's fog of war and there's
propaganda but dude like nobody nobody
mass-produced big fake videos uh and got
these guys to go on TV and admit to
doing these things mhm I mean this is
how I felt when we got involved with
Ukraine right what is the American
interest here and do we actually have
one I understand calls for you know you
got to protect innocent people and you
know whatever but ultimately all of
these things are much more nuanced
conflicts than the American Media
presents to the people and we use it to
justify investing tons and tons of money
into stuff that I'm not sure is in the
best interest of American people I want
to play this clip for you guys this is a
tweet from Julio roses Andy no has quote
tweeted it at the Hamas celebration
rally in Times Square organized by the
far-left Socialists and Palestinian
nationalists a speaker talks about the
islamist attacks that killed hundreds of
Israelis mostly civilians the crowd
cheers I uh I hope you're ready to hear
this this is It's just awful and pared
across sorry early morning on Saturday
October 7th our resistance stormed
illegal settlements and parag glided
across col
War the lar military Bas
around all right in this operation and
office of you of the resistance fires
more than 5,000
Rockets wait for
it reaching T Aviv do you hear that
reaching T reaching Tel Aviv okay
in in in in a conflict uh let's say
you're you're in a prison you're you're
in a prison they say it's an open air
prison you're locked up and you're like
it is unjust I was put here against my
will and my parents were here and so you
decide to start bombing the town next
door with a bunch of civilians who live
nearby I I just you're not breaking out
you're not it's like a Sally out kind of
if you're in a if you're in a Siege
situation and you're the one that's
under siege sometimes they'll Sally out
and try and cause havoc in the enemy
camp the enemy Siege camp and then come
back and and kill as much and Destroy as
much as they can that's kind of what
this was was a well imagine
if they didn't kill a bunch of civilians
targeted the military only and were seen
on video clearing civilians out and
telling them to get back and then issu
issued a statement saying you know our
issue is with the occupying force of the
Israeli government who have oppressed
and suppressed us we will take every
every effort to protect the lives of
civilians that's not what they're doing
they're outright saying in quotes they
will execute civilians to get what they
want there is evil in this world it's
not tactically smart from their
standpoint either because now there's
justification for them being completely
wiped out yep yeah so this this video in
particular just reminds me of pavo's dog
right they say she says colonizers and
the crowd who's all raised in the west
they're all American cheer because they
know from every Public School history
lesson that the word colonization is
always bad I mean they can't see that
there might be any bias in this I mean
obviously they've chosen to go to this
so they have their own own leaning but
but with this argument it's it's just I
don't I don't know I I hate that this is
something that people are going to
decide they have an opinion on all of a
sudden because of the media media slant
because really it's an area of the world
that most people don't understand well
enough to truly understand what's going
on they have signs at this protest
saying end us funding of
Israel many of the people who are
arguing that we not fund Israel it's not
a principled argument about America
First and saving the American people it
is is them secretly trying to get Israel
to be in a weakened position so that
they can start genociding people that's
it look I'm not saying that Israelis
like Palestinians I'm not saying that at
all I'm saying these people here are
referring to Hamas as their Fighters
there's another video where they say the
same thing where these activists and
pales and there's many there's
Palestinians here outright say that
Hamas is them and they're doing this
intentionally Constantine kissen made an
excellent tweet I think it was yesterday
and saying you you people in the west
and he was kind of like it's like you
you've been told for so long that they
hate you for your freedom and it's not
that they hate you because you have more
power than them and if they had more
power than you they would conquer you
colonize you and turn you into something
much worse so get your head straight and
I I've been so anti-war I put it in
quotes but like for 20 years like no
don't but like I can only fathom what
would happen if the United States was
taken over by Marauders or barbarians
that would rape and kill like that would
be incable we cannot allow that to
happen this is the far left they they
the the Democratic socialists of America
promoted this rally and at this rally
they celebrated the targeting of
civilians okazi Cortez is a card
carrying member of the democratic
socialists of America has she spoken up
about it I don't think so other than the
squad called for a ceasefire which is
just I just look man yes okay we don't
want any more fighting but you are hard
pressed to be like hey we stormed and
killed a bunch of civilians took a bunch
of hostages now seiz fire it just seems
like arrog on their part right what we
called for it over here in America so
you guys should stop I think they
thought the Hamas perhaps thought that
uh taking the hostages would prevent any
kind of retaliation and they
miscalculated and then when the bomb
started dropping in Gaza they were like
we need to stop this right now why stop
retaliation no no they're saying they're
going to they're going to execute the
civilians in in in response to now the
bombs but I think they thought that if
they took the civilians a lot of
captives then they they have some time I
disagree uh the Alazan Brigade sets up
rocket Depot in hospitals and schools
and residential areas on purpose to
force Israel to strike civilian targets
and then comply at they're striking
civilian targets the argument from any
the Palestine side is where should their
resistance fighter set up at all because
there's no there's there's no military
bases there and where do the people go
what do we do do we take them in as
refugees into the United States no well
a lot of people are saying expect to see
you know millions of refugees now and
this is another thing which maybe we'll
touch on you talk about an open border
hundreds of thousands of people coming
across how many of those people are like
Sleeper
Cell It's a serious concern right this
is true of of all kinds of things U
saying you're a refugee doesn't necess
me and that that's terrible because
there are people in awful positions who
do need support and help but opening
every Border in the US because we've
decided to get involved in wars that we
are ultimately not sure how we're going
to end anyways is sort of not the
solution right we're creating more
problems for everyone all the time time
it's I mean it it is one of the reasons
that you have to be so critical of the
Biden Administration which is that they
they were not uh proactive On the Border
the way they should have been and they
have also been club-footed when it comes
to International diplomacy they have not
put American in strong position so we're
actually in a in my opinion not a very
strong position to help anyone in any
way so for for there are a lot of
reasons for this and I'm not trying to
put anyone on the spot this not a
rhetorical question a little question
for you guys for what reason is the US
providing military funding to Israel um
to protect the Suez Canal it just
depends on how you're looking at it well
that's Egypt though that's a Sinai
Peninsula yeah but Israel's got war war
planes and Egypt's also on on our side
our side it's on the side right but
Israel is not on the Suz is controlled
by Egypt um shipping maybe but well I
mean they it kind of guards the Suez
it's not obviously the Suz is in Egypt
yeah it's a it's a it's a it's yeah it's
on the uh so the Sinai Peninsula is
where the Suez is and then you have um
Israel further east of there so perhaps
there's a strategic military you know
point because it gives them the Eastern
side of the sus it always was too
because the Romans would sail over there
well they would do it through Egypt but
then they would pick their boats up and
walk them across before the canal was
ever built and then put it back down and
then sail to India I mean that it
probably is the most logical reason the
control of canals is massive I mean
right now we're looking you the conflict
in Ukraine has a lot to do with the
Bosphorus uh the BOS was the Bosphorus
straight that's going through turkey
that gets from that that uh uh opens up
the Black Sea to the Mediterranean so
taking Russia's warm water port in
Crimea if NATO were to acquire or the EU
were to absorb uh Ukraine would be very
bad for Russia so now Russia is trying
to secure this whole land re this whole
land bridge into Crimea because that's
where they have access to the Black Sea
and then there's other there's other
points of access they have into the
Black Sea into the Black Sea as well but
this is a major Naval base for them and
then of course you have what what may be
the Suz obviously the Panama Canal was
massive and strategically important for
us to control and I think it was like 10
years ago China was trying to build a
Nicaraguan Canal which is insane because
the land mass is massive whereas Panama
is very thin and then uh with the
Nicaraguan Canal they would have to
decimate this natural aquafer that
everyone got water from ultimately I
think the the the the uh program was
abandoned however but it could be it
could be that the US we hear this all
the time that Israel's our most
important Ally in the region I'm like
okay I guess in the sense that in terms
of the form of govern government and the
perception like the the the world view
yes that makes sense but what is the
actual strategic military purpose I
wonder anybody got a better idea than
the Suez I mean that's what I would say
I mean I think ultimately America thinks
of itself as historically Israel's Ally
and so it feels the need to intervene um
it's it's a question that I think
everyone should ask themselves like what
really is the Strategic purpose of
getting involved at this point uh and I
don't I honestly don't have a great
answer for it and I think lot of
Americans will feel that way so should
we continue to you know we've already
moved uh military ships closer to Israel
we are preparing to get involved if in
in in more ways than we are are already
now um we already spent billions of
dollars on Ukraine this year I mean this
is not something that we can really do
we're going into an election I wonder if
this is the strike is partly because
they know the US is fractured and and
distracted yeah speaking of distracted
Jack pic tweeted out earlier here it is
White House staffer this from two hours
ago this is he's saying that this is
from a White House staffer uh Biden
keeps bringing up Ukraine during
briefings on Israel he's getting the two
Wares mixed up Austin Lloyd Austin
secretary uh what is Secretary of
Defense Secretary of Defense uh barely
showing up to the to them anymore the
meetings anymore uh blinkin making more
decisions than anyone so you talk about
confusion within the leadership of the
United States right now
Biden Biden is he's probably concerned
about getting caught for his business
yeah and also you know we've all had
concerns about Biden's mental faculties
always so maybe it's just you know the
old age catching up with him you you
know they had a barbecue yesterday they
were at a barbecue at the White House
Biden and his wife and a bunch of White
House staff or the day before yesterday
like during the bombs dropping in Israel
Biden's throwing a party well yeah but
to be fair during dur the bomb cancel
the party dur the War Room what no
during the bombs going off in Sudan or
or Somalia they're also having barbecues
yeah but it's
so so what this this is another the
problem I have with many of the people
who are like we need to intervene in
Ukraine or you Israel's our Ally I'm
like China's running concentration camps
where they're genociding weager Muslims
are we are we going to are we going to
go to every single country on the planet
whenever a bomb Falls no but if your one
of your Military Allies is under attack
you go to the war room and that's where
you stay for the next 28 hours or
whatever I was on Twitter for like 12
hours yesterday Biden can do it he
should be that's he's our commander he's
a military commander when bombs Dro
Commander Go to War Room considering and
I I will I I accept this considering the
severity of the escalation yes I agree
that he should have been but it does
frustrate me that the news goes nuts
when like Ukraine goes off and I'm like
a border dispute with Russia and a
neighboring Nation why do I care why
aren't we talking about what's going on
in say these these African nations or
with the Armenians I mean we we didn't
intervene with the IRA uh way back in
the day there are definitely there's
always been a stance that we pick and
choose and I'm glad that you brought up
the weer Muslims because we still sent
our Olympic team we made a big show of
saying we're not going to send any of
our officials or diplomates yet we still
went with it I mean the double standard
for what we are allowed to be outraged
on humanitarian platforms it's just
ridiculous and I think ultimately we
know that this is not based on any sort
of uh bleeding heart dedication to
anything it's always about something
strategic and powerful and in this case
we've already put ourselves in a weak
position so what are we I think that's
like I can't get past the point of what
is the purpose of this I just my
question is what what about Israel makes
people's brains stop working no question
I think it's just like what because of
religion because of Judaism they feel so
connected to the land
itself I'm not talking about people who
are Jewish or Israeli I'm talking about
right now on Twitter right now even in
our chats there are people whose like
brains shut off the moment the subject
of Israel comes up they stop listening
to arguments they when it comes to
Ukraine you can have a rational
conversation about intervention Israel
happens and it's just like
hyperpolarized no matter what you say
you're wrong no matter what you say
you're right it's just there there's
there's no rational thought whatsoever
it's the most annoying thing in the
world I used to have a a chat
server and um the most annoying thing in
the world was people always tried to
make Israel a subject like to talk about
it when it was not even in the news
there whatever it is
there there are places in the world
right now where there are tribal
factions locking up oppressing beating
and murdering other factions there are
they they're China for instance but for
some reason it's Israel it pisses it's
so annoying I'm like hey okay let's like
check out the history of what's going on
and they're like the the the people
right now the conspiracy theory is that
uh Israel knew it was going to happen
and let it happen so they could justify
flattening Gaza and it's just
like okay dude yeah I heard at any point
everyone is just going to choose what
they want to be the reality yeah okay
there are videos of thing happening if
you're going to make the assumptions
that Israel knew there's a report saying
Egypt warned warned them of something
big 10 days ago that doesn't mean
anything saying hey something's coming
watch out something big what are they
supposed to what are they going to act
on that okay I guess we'll secure
something or what we'll look for
something big but people just lose their
minds and
they man I we we've had people on this
show where it's they just get really
really really angry at the subject and
start ranting about it I'm like what is
up with people dude certainly World War
II the way Hitler exterminated 6 million
according to historical records of
Jewish people has caused an emotional
attachment to just the entire concept of
Judaism and extermination of humanity so
that's a big part of it it's like never
again kind of mentality like I can't
even go there I can't even consider that
and it's like because it happened and
and honestly the Jewish population has
been for whatever reason persecuted
throughout history in different
countries I think in England they were
actually kicked out of the country by
one of the Kings of England at one point
just completely tossed out because of
their I don't know Bank what was it uh
it has to do with user and the fact they
allow user with it's a whole other thing
it's a whole other
thing well let's jump to uh more
American domestic politics in relation
to this we have this from firstpost.com
did the weapons Hamas used against
Israel come from Ukraine or Afghanistan
asks us congresswoman margorie Taylor
green says we need to work with Israel
to track serial numbers on any Us
weapons used by Hamas against Israel did
they come from Afghanistan did they come
from Ukraine highly likely the answer is
both I don't completely disagree I mean
I don't know for sure what we need is
evidence but we have this from Jim
Ferguson on Twitter Jim Ferguson UK he
is former parliamentary candidate with
the brexit party in barnesley reporting
breaking news Israel Us weapons left
behind in Afghanistan used to attack
Israel a high- ranking Israel uh Israel
Defense Forces Commander said Us weapons
left in Afghanistan by the Biden
administration were found in the hands
of Palestinian groups active in the Gaza
Strip the chaos that erupted after the
US scrambled to evacuate Afghanistan as
ordered by Biden and the significant
amount of weapons and equipment left
behind there has now been used to attack
Israel a close Ally of the US Biden is
incapable of leadership and a total
embarrassment on the world stage I don't
know that any of this is confirmed right
we have this
I wonder if it works this is uh amage
news I don't know what this source is
take these things with a grain of salt
this is a story from June 18th 2023
weapons left by the US in Afghanistan
reach the hands of Palestinian militants
says Israel and again this is from June
so it may be the case and I think it is
fair to say considering the taliban's
desire to support uh Gaza the
Palestinians it makes sense that the
weapons that they got got control over
would would fall into the hands of uhuh
the
Palestinians now uh the bigger picture I
suppose is whether or not any of this is
true it as I me as I mentioned a moment
ago people when it comes to Israel
Palestine their brains shut off I'm I'm
sorry I'm not saying literally everyone
maybe not you guys but it's impossible
to have conversations with people about
this we've even had guests like I
mentioned who just lose it and can't
hear reason their brains are just not
working the point is that being said
this will be tremendously bad for Joe
Biden when have anistan happened Joe
Biden lost something like 15 points in
the polls I imag Netanyahu cannot stand
the guy I imagine he finds no comfort in
uh Biden being around being in control
you want to call it uh obviously the
surrender of military equipment and
human life to the Taliban in Afghanistan
was one of those egregious losses of
American Military right I mean this this
theory is even on the table because
Biden handled Afghanistan so poorly
right we can't totally know for sure you
know I I agree with him take it a little
with a Grandin of assault but the fact
that we know weapons and other supplies
were left behind means that this is on
the table in the first place which again
is a direct responsibility of the Biden
Administration I I don't understand how
anyone can defend Biden going into 2024
given the record and the position that
he has put everyone in in the last what
two years of his presidency but I don't
like that everyone is kind of jumping on
the Biden Administration and trying to
blame America for this conflict this
conflict has been going on for a long
time to say the least for sure for sure
and everyone wants to always attribute
things to America like oh they released
the aid to the uh sanctions on Iran so
they got 6 billion it's like that hasn't
been confirmed we don't know that Iran
directly directed this attack we don't
know that the funds were directly used
but what we're seeing are people like
Senator Lindsey Graham and the neocons
in the Republican Party trying to score
points against Biden and saying we need
to B bom Iran's oil refineries when we
don't even know what the facts are yet
we don't even know we don't know the
extent of this stuff ex someone pointed
that out about Lindsey Graham he's
almost 70 and has no kids so he has like
nothing to
lose he want hey look I'll tell you what
not here for a long time he wants to put
on the cowboy hat and ride the atomic
bomb down and like uh what was that was
that Dr Str I actually visualized him
going to the front lines in his his fat
body he would not Lindy come on Lyn dude
what hey look man I'm look I if you tell
me that you're in favor of uh funding
and support for any country no matter
what it is Israel or Ukraine hey man I
got some uh military pts we got some
ammo we we we'll suit you up we'll put
you in basic training we'll send you
right off first light and when I
visualize him going he'd be like I'm too
old to go but it's okay for your
relatives and Sons and children to go
it's fine with him dude what the hey man
look you know more people is still
better right so if you're in favor of
going to war with any country like I got
to we we could suit you up you know what
I mean so the people who are all for
intervention in Ukraine it's like let's
suit you up buddy like I and and look a
lot of the people did go that's crazy
remember that guy from what was that
MSNBC guy who went to Ukraine oh yeah
yeah was that I don't remember who it
was either that fake video or he pointed
and didn't he pretend that there was
like an air strike or something when
there was no there was like there was
like a you heard a sound of a jet or
something or boming and he goes he's
like one two bomb three bombings that's
what's happening it's like oh shut up
dude yeah those look man at least went
there I guess reminds me of that movie
Edge of Tomorrow when they're like going
to send Town cruise to the front line
like and Malcolm Nance you're going in
but hey look look I'm not saying that
Israel is right or wrong I'm just saying
if you want military funding for any of
these countries Lindsey Graham wants to
bomb bomb Iran bro I will put you in
that plane you can pull the lever let's
get you let's get you going buddy my
point is this they won't do it no no
they want you they want your kids to go
die for this yeah that's sick you know I
think this is not a war of Islam against
Judaism I think it's a war of release us
from this open air prison no I don't
think it's a religious thing because
it's been a religious for dude that
doesn't explain it's always been for for
land it's always been for land even
though they Hezbollah exists okay all
right Iran has stated they want to kill
Jews they'll use it to Rally it is not
about but I'm thinking about 911 which
is why I brought it up because they said
it's the it's the Muslims that want it
no we wanted the oil in the Middle East
so we went in and took it and we said
muslim Muslim we caused all this chaos
and it was just like that was stupid of
me because now I'm I'm like I want to
I'm thinking like dude the worst threat
we could face is Islamic terrorist it's
not okay it is terrorism in general but
I think the Russians are Christian I
mean the Russians are like Orthodox
Christian they they should be on our
side defending what's right you know
what's what's good and right I'm not
saying it's a but I don't want it to
turn into some religious thing it's just
we got to we got to call a white piece
in in Ukraine and start working together
to defend
Earth I mean I don't think Ukraine wants
to Ukraine Ukraine and Russia have not
uh successfully worked out a peace deal
I'll say that and I think it would be
impossible to say okay guys we've got a
new world conflict so you guys just take
a pause and we'll move on I mean what
I'm waiting for next is anything to
happen in Taiwan because everyone can
tell that we are on the brink of very
serious chaos and I think everyone knows
the US doesn't have strong leadership I
agree with your point we can't blame the
Biden Administration for everything
there are lots of historical factors
going in I just know that in the last
three years we have not positioned
ourselves the way I would like to be
going into this kind of conflict and
there's a question about whether the
American the leadership of the American
federal government uh is best serving
the American people I can't say
internationally what's going on we we
can blame the Biden Administration yeah
I mean look we can reduce any argument
we can go further and further back what
was the real cause of World War II World
War I what was the real cause of World
War I okay fine at a certain point we
talk about the the actions here under
Donald Trump Abram Accords normalization
of relations between Israel and many
Arabic Nations Donald Trump no new Wars
and while there was budding conflict
with Ukraine and Russia under Obama it
stops when Trump gets in weird Trump
actually starts investigating this uh uh
this corruption how strange Isis
decimated the intention of the existing
Administration the unip party in this
country is to perpetuate War for their
Neo liberal new world order whatever you
want to call it those are their words
not mine when they say the what do they
call the liberal world order and the
liberal economic order or the new world
order again it was the CFR that called
it a new world order whatever or I think
they also call it like the American L
liberal economic order they they'll
specify that it was an American Le thing
Trump's attitude is like we're going to
secure our borders and bring
manufacturing back and mind our own
business and everyone else was like well
okay that sounds good to us and then
Biden gets in and he's like I'm going to
blow him up and now we've got War
everywhere it's just crazy so yeah I'm
sorry it's like at a certain point I'm
not going to go into the nitty-gritty of
all the class documents to determine was
Russia biting their time and it was just
a coincidence that all this happened the
way it did and just be like nah the
simple answer is this under Donald Trump
no war under Joe Biden lots of War I
think it's Biden administration's fault
yeah and Trump even had Bolton in Trump
at one point told Putin that if he
aggressed he would uh Trump would nuke
Moscow he told Shan ping that as well
and then he I think he was like I don't
know if he believed me but it was F even
if it was 5% that's enough Trump said
that and he's right yeah it's it's any
kind of doubt I mean he was the one who
cared No One Believes that Biden could
do the same thing and I think I don't
know I I don't want to I know we're
going to talk about uh RFK Jr in a
second but I just really think this is
one of the the moments that Democrats
are going to have to evaluate if they
can get behind the Biden Administration
for a second I think this this this this
might be it for him this is going to
destroy what the Biden his base is like
Pro Palestine I mean I I think so him
sending support to Israel immediately
you don't think the far left face no the
the average Democrat voter probably
doesn't know or care at all and might
just give you a generic but we support
Israel far- leftists will vote for Joe
Biden because they're crazy people and
but not all of them did but but a lot of
them did a lot of these prominent
leftists and antifa people who have big
social media followings endorsed Joe
Biden and said like we're we got to
support him because Trump's a fascist so
they did uh they they support Palestine
but but Joe Biden's actual voter base
which is the default liberal is probably
more align with
Israel the ignorant masses yeah the
ignorant masses all they hear is Dem R
saying like Israel's an ally we must
protect them and they go yeah the far-
leftists are like Palestinians you know
from the river to Sea etc etc and then
you have conservatives who understand
quite a bit more and overtly support
Israel not all of them but a lot of them
and then you have Libertarians who don't
want us involved in any of it that
actually is not working for me anymore I
used to I used to start to think along
those lines of non- interven
interventionism but uh not anymore why
what changed um I I thought a lot about
World War II and if we hadn't gotten
involved in World War II what would have
happened Hitler would have taken over
the world I really don't think so I mean
he was about to he took France he took
France in like three weeks taking over
the world is a very very bold and kind
of crazy statement considering I I he
would have taken Europe he would taken
Britain he would have taken Europe he
would taken Britain and he would have
murdered lots and lots of innocent
people but the world is a bit much you
know right now they're saying like
Vladimir Putin is going to take Poland
I'm like oh shut up come on no way come
on not going to happen no way you know
they're like they're saying like the
Russian forces are decimated and they're
losing and Ukraine's winning but he'll
take
Poland dude I think I was saying was it
before the show I've been so accustomed
to false Flags just because golf of
tonen I was talking to my dad he was
like oh yeah that was he went he served
in Vietnam he was in the Navy and he
remembers the false so that I'm like so
anti- intervent invent interventionalist
but uh then sometimes people just get
attacked sometimes your country gets
invaded and I've never lived that life
because I'm from the United States in
the late 90s you know where we never got
invaded But now sometimes it it just
sometimes it can happen and you got to
be realistic about that there's no time
to Waffle if your country is under
attack you can't let the a hot air
balloon float all the way across your
land mass like you split second decis
balloon that we did let float Across
America yeah asinine and Montana was
like wait there's something here and we
were just like who knows we'll just see
what happens oh wait we shot it down
later I mean I I get you know the desire
to sort of feel like you you need to act
right but in in this case you have to go
back to like our government is to serve
the American people and what is
ultimately the best interest of the
American people I can understand an
argument for we have allies we've made
agreements we've made deals but you know
I think the president has the duty to
the American people first and we can't
forget that I want to pull up this story
from CNN 11 US citizens dead in Israel
conflict Biden says and then we have
this from ABC Biden says it is likely
Americans are among Hamas hostages with
11 killed I don't see how Biden can
recover from this electorally he's
already down and now you have it it it
doesn't matter what you think it's true
in fact doesn't even matter what is true
it matters what people end up believing
is true certainly I do believe the truth
matters and we try our best to get to it
but the political ads are all going to
say one simple line under Donald Trump
historic peace agreements with Israel
under Joe Biden 11 Americans dead in
escalating conflict Afghanistan
withdrawal it's just he's going to these
these his I I don't see how he he pulls
out of this yeah when it comes to
military I think you realize that
nothing else really matters when when
your survival is on the line I haven't
heard the word Trans in like three days
I don't I haven't seen anything about
culture War crap on Twitter maybe one or
two things it's all been about the death
and destruction and potential loss of
life that's all that really matters when
it comes down to it well it is
indigenous people's day and that is a
big thing and I didn't even know that
until like 4:00 and I was like are we
doing a show tonight it's Columbus T oh
well I I I I see Israel Palestine Gaza
in my Twitter feed and I'm glad um we
need a strong military commander that's
what we need right now I think I I sorry
Ian you were saying you're not you used
to be anti- intervention you're not
anymore would you support us
intervention in Israel um yes in fact
yes immediate intervention and For
Better or Worse to to help bring water
to the people of Gaza for starters well
that's in Palestine I guess but like so
in the region you're saying yes to
intervention I would I would like to
facilitate some sort of peace deal I I'm
not I'm not advocating for blowing
people up at and you and millions of
people for Generations would like to
broker a pieace deal good luck yeah but
uh yeah absolutely I think we need to be
it's we're the strongest military force
on Earth we need to be so what do you
think you think like us boots on the
ground TR no no Israel is capable Tak
you're not talking about in intervention
you're talking about you like said
capable of taking care itself then
military aid what do you want us to do
I'm we're on TV man I can't really I
can't really say that stuff on TV Biden
ad ation already announced they're
giving weapons to Israel yeah for this
right now so that's already
happened I I support it I absolutely
support it man whether or not whether or
not they let this thing happen those
dudes murdered raped like they they were
they killed a from what I'm reading
about this music festival did they rape
they killed people and then they raped
women right next to their friends dead
corpses that's true this is what I've
been reading I don't this is all I mean
that could be propaganda bro it could be
it could be maybe the whole thing I
don't know a lot of it is and so watch
out cuz when Ukraine the Ukraine war
started all that look let's be honest
Israel is so much better at propaganda
than but I think two things that a man
needs and will kill for is eating and
having sex and if these men are militar
and there are no women in their society
oh you better believe they want to have
sex yeah but they're not it's not like
these guys were like oh I'm so angry I
want to it's more like these evil
oppressors will know when we control
them and they want to sub subjugate the
people that they they they view as
oppressors right it's a display of
brutality yeah and then the psychotic
urges of masculinity come out when
they're in battle after after the kill
the man wants well it's it's it's not
that it's it's you're you're you're
you're thinking of it it's it's it's a
lot of it is spitting in the face of the
of Israel taking taking the women is an
insult to is Israel it was it was known
throughout time like when a when a
Alexander the Great's forces or like a a
military force would invade and take a
city the commander would have to tell
the troops do not pillage do not raap
and a shitty Commander wouldn't be able
to keep his troops under ws and they
just go destroy and so like a good
Commander would keep his men from doing
it but it was just the the um proclivity
for a you know a worn out dude that just
got done putting his life on the line
his adrenaline's all burned out he's got
women all around him now and he hasn't
had sex in two years okay do you think
we should say put boots on the ground to
uh to liberate the weager Muslims in
China no why why not because uh China
would launch nuclear weapons if we tried
to do that oh okay so it's only because
the the people in Palestine can't
actually do anything else retaliation
that we should actually try and stop
them well no well no no no I don't I'm
not saying that we should put boots on
the ground or anything I think Israeli
soldiers are qualified and capable of
handling that situation right now if
there's I heard Hezbollah may be making
moves in the north um if there's an
actual full scale Invasion into Israel
and they call for help we have to help I
don't even want to but I mean why do
that mean if you're saying we shouldn't
have boots on the ground how do you want
us to help like what just I'm just
really curious like um because if
neither side is willing to the table and
negotiate peace what is all the way
nuclear war what so we shouldn't have
boots on the ground but you want to go
to nuclear war well we're talking about
life and death of the human race you
have to put that on the table what do
you mean we're talking nuclear war means
death for all of us yeah my question is
like why do you care about Israel to the
point where we you think we should
intervene and provide aid but no other
countries um maybe because it's probably
like our third strongest Ally maybe next
to Germany and if they go down I think
that China Russia North Korea and Iran
will take over the
world World War I but Israel is capable
fully capable they're an advanced
technologically advanced military they
are fully capable on their own of
defeating Hamas so I think a danger here
is that Israel this goes into a broader
war and Israel has in the back of their
mind well if we get into trouble the US
will bail us out that's dangerous we
don't want them thinking well if this
does escalate the US will bail us out
because then we're all of a sudden in a
really dangerous situation mhm do you
feel like Trump would have handled this
differently from your time in his
administration you know I don't know how
he would be handling it I think I think
that Trump would fully support Israel's
right to self-defense and fighting
against Hamas and and defeating them but
I think Trump is known for his restraint
and there was a similar incident where
um Saudi Arabia did a or there was some
kind of drone attack and they blamed
Iran it was it was in Yemen they blamed
Iran for a drone attack um that was
against Saudi Arabia's interest in Yemen
and Trump people were calling on Trump
to attack Iran and Trump didn't go for
it he said no absolutely not like this
isn't our conflict we're not getting
involved in it well he specifically said
that the amount of people who would die
in the retaliation strike was not worth
it it was it was uh uh it was not what's
the right word kzer yeah that's right
word not wor opportunity cost was too
great yeah you could say that to it it
it wasn't um I can't think of the
opportunity cost men is that what you
thinking of well it it was proportional
proportional there you go it wasn't
proportional the the the the Drone
attack you know killing hundreds of of
you know militants is way the harsh
reality of War sometimes is you want a
nonproportional response in order to
make it all stop before it escalates
it's horrible to think this big stick
ethos that was what a lot of Americans
in World War II thought with the nuclear
weapons oh we got got stung by wasp
let's go find the wasp nest and
annihilate it kind of thing well I mean
that's a little different
similar if you if people are getting
stung by wasps you probably want to get
rid of the wasps nest you better you you
don't just take out the few wasps that
stung you but we're not we're not
talking about so that would be a
proportional response right yeah see Ian
eradicate all of them if one of them
stings you yeah but what you're arguing
is a a wasp stung you so you brought a
flamethrower and you wanted all the
other
wasps want the other wasps to watch it
so that they would not sting you ever
again that's what you're saying I don't
want them to suffer I just want to make
it
stop well you I don't want to like burn
them alive I just want the conflict to
stop I don't want to like make make them
die in pain but that doesn't mean that I
don't want them what the hell are we
doing there's no there's no solving this
I'm sorry it's War it's war and people
have chosen a side in the war have a
nice day this goes back a 100 plus years
or even longer you can right you can go
thousands of years and it's like
everyone going to be like this land
belongs to this no this man belongs I'm
right no I'm right in the end bro I'm 37
years old this has been going on a lot
longer than I've been alive my response
is whoa why are they killing all the
civilians and what do I get Tim Israel
is an AP paride State and these people
are Freedom Fighters and I'm like bro
they're killing civilians why are you
supporting Israel Israel is is getting
stealing our money America I'm like dude
I don't care about any of this yeah like
I'm talking about these arguments what
I'm telling you is the war is bad
civilians shouldn't be dying you can't
come to me and like Israel should not be
uh uh targeting should not be taking
action against uh uh the Hamas targets
and the alasan brigades and I'm like
what they're shooting at him the AR like
what's the what's the argument you walk
outside and a guy's got a Ruger 1022 and
he's firing at you and he hits some of
your kids so and the only weapon and so
you pull out your you know your scar 20s
and then you're like I'm going to return
fire like whoa but yours is way bigger
than his it kind of feels like War's War
dude when the American colonists were
colonizing the North America and
slaughtering the native population it's
similar to that but we didn't have
internet video back we'd had the same
conversation like well you know but what
Happ the natives would come into town
the gorilla Force they'd Tomahawk some
dudes grab some women take them back to
the tribe and then the Americans would
go with their rifles and Slaughter all
of them well there's there's two things
there's two things with that a lot of
the Plains Indians that was the regular
life for Plains Indians that was an
understanding of Plains Indians
attacking other Indians within within
the United States understanding that's
what was going to happen to men and
Indigenous people right
exactly from this company IND indigenous
people in this country whatever you want
to call them that was the understanding
plan plans IND the end that's how life
was that was the understanding that's
what they did to us they didn't take it
and it wasn't special for them in any
way this is different because as far as
I understand this regions and West Bank
Gaza ETA were not really inhabited until
Israel became a state and there was
reason to be able to support populations
in those areas and they immigrated into
it that's what I understand about it I
may be wrong but that's what I
understand so I don't think it's the
same thing indigenous people versus
people that move migrated there after
there was a state established and allow
them to survive in those areas I don't
know if that's exactly the same it's not
comparable yeah no it's not comparable I
wouldn't I wouldn't say it is but you
know like the colony of Israel and like
1918 the the British mandate for
Palestine was 1948 that was 1948 that
was much later much later than that well
that's when Israel got formed but the
British mandate start was in 1918 you
ever read I Am Legend um no I've seen
the movie the movie is is nothing the
movie does not relate to the story at
all the movie should never have been
made right and that it's awful the book
is much better and uh fully admit I did
not read it uh I've only seen the select
passages that convey the general concept
of what the book is about and the book
is about a guy who is um he's a vampire
hunter and he kills vampires because
vampires are bad and then in the end he
finally realizes that because the world
has fallen to vampires and he is one of
the last
humans he is the legend from the
perspective of humans there's a legend
of vampires that in the middle of the
night come and kill you while you sleep
when the world became all vampires there
was a legend of a man who lurks during
the day and kills you in your sleep that
was his realization that they arrested
him and were to try him for the crimes
of murder and and they were terrified of
him he was a monster he was the monster
in the in um 2005 6 78 I was like screw
Israel theyve they've colonized this is
unjust it should be dismantled I was in
that state of mind and then I started to
realize like that life is about power
and who controls the power controls the
narrative and your lifestyle so I'm not
willing to give up this American
republicanism for like some
anti-colonialism I'm just not man I just
don't know what the proposed solution is
right now when you have Israel for all
their faults and then Palestinians don't
want peace they want from the river to
the Sea these are act like they'll lie
to you the left lies to you the left
lies to you all the time we know they
lie we know farle lies they are evil
people they lie lie lie they're trying
to sterilize children they want you to
abort your kids they do a whole bunch of
things and then they go in politics they
lie there's a video where Jack bobic got
punched in the in the face and the cops
witnessed it and the far-left activists
say to the cops I didn't see anything
happen they just lie with a smug look on
their face you have videos of these
people in New York amongst their peers
cheering for the killing of civilians
calling them illegal colonizers we as
regular regular people are like okay we
can understand the nuances of military
conflict don't like these these stories
we're being told but will not tolerate
civilians at Music Festival being just
murdered and dragged to the streets then
they'll lie and say oh but our poor
civilians will make propaganda videos
what is what what does one do right now
right now I don't know about anything
else all I know is I'm sitting here
right now looking at the conflict and
I'm like I've been to Israel there are
people going to the store and buying
Falafel they're not fighting with each
other why should they be murdered by
Hamas and alasan brigades they shouldn't
be okay well what happens when these
terrorists come in and start killing
civilians like they just did in the
worst possible way we've seen ever
should Israel just be like well you know
it is what it is we're being killed no
they shouldn't the reality is we want
peace we want a peace agreement
unfortunately I think overwhelmingly it
falls to the Palestinians and the
ideologues more so Hamas but yes in many
ways the Palestinians they just want to
to purge Israel completely what do you
do that's not a solution that's not
there's no compromise if they're saying
we don't care what you want to negotiate
we will kill everyone I'm like okay well
there's no negotiating with these people
and and we're not going to let you just
go and kill a bunch of Jewish people in
Israel now you want to make an argument
that Israel's shouldn't be there or
whatever it's like okay fine but bro the
only thing they're offering is genocide
I I there's no argument there's no
there's no compromise and Israel is
there like we can't we can't go back and
take change anything like that I mean I
I really stand by that peace deals
always means that someone is upset
because they lost right in this case
you're completely right there's there's
not a clear compromise and so as much as
we'd like to see a ceasefire as much as
we wouldn't like to see people lost and
we wouldn't like to see civilians taken
hostage like we can all agree these
things are bad on the other hand it's
not like we can just be like hey guys
stop stop fighting just stop like that's
it's obviously not a reasonable solution
it's not logical in any way the United
States can't solve this yeah right
exactly you know and I don't I don't
know why it's it's insane to me that
people are so fervent about it because
it's like I got an idea let's uh secure
our borders bring manufacturing back to
this country get rid of these garbage
International agreements like TPP make
America great again and then when people
are like you're about the conflict
happening and uh no I didn't because I'm
concerned about our borders which are
currently poorest and have millions of
people this is an example of one of
Jesus's Parables when said take the
plank out of your own eye before you try
and take the speck of dust out of your
brother's eye or your friend or whatever
like clean yourself up nice one dude you
got to clean your room yeah before you
try and clean up the world Peterson
Parable that's right here's the story
from the Associated Press RFK Jr's
independent run for president draws GOP
criticism and Silence from National
Democrats this I find fascinating
Republicans attacked Ark Jr on Monday as
the longtime Environmental Lawyer blah
blah blah now threatening to take votes
from former president Donald Trump I
believe this is prop aganda and a lie
the Republican National Committee in
Trump's campaign both took aim at
Kennedy's liberal background while
National Democrats stayed silent as
Kennedy insisted in a speech in
Philadelphia quote voters should not be
deceived by anyone who pretends to have
conservative values said Trump
spokesperson Stephen Chung in a
statement he labeled Kennedy's campaign
nothing more than a vanity project for a
liberal Kennedy looking to cash in on
his family's name it's really funny
because um Democrats are hurt by this
not not Donald Trump I don't know if
y'all watched his speech where he talked
about finally the United States can
recognize indigenous people's day and
stand up you know blah blah blah left
woke talking point and said he wants to
have a new Declaration of Independence
Independence from the corporations that
are doing all these things and I'm like
I don't see this guy pulling any Trump
voters he
might uh the crowd looked to be more
liberal leaning and cheering for him
saying indigenous people's day I think
this Narrative of criticism from the GOP
is because they're trying to keep
Democrats unified and they want RFK to
to be seen as Trump the way they stop
RFK from pulling votes from Democrats is
by convincing Democrats that RFK Jr is a
trump supporter or a trump in in some
way yeah and Trump and he teed himself
up to have this moment in his speech
where he could have potentially really
courted Trump voters and then he Let It
Go I mean he did say a lot of really
interesting stuff along the way and I
thought it was perfectly fine uh he said
at one point you know his his big tenant
was uh we need to give up our addiction
to picking sides and I thought that was
a great great sentiment right so many
people don't want to hear anything they
know they're supposed to fall under a
certain label or side of a certain party
so they just continue to agree with it
no matter what he was saying uh for
example over the past six months I've
really started to listen to different
people and I've gone to the border and
I've talked to border patrol agents and
migrants and people in the community and
I've really started to think rethink my
position on this and then he moved on he
didn't say so I would commit to building
the wall so I would commit to ending
Birthright citizenship he didn't take
any strong Republican talking points he
just continued to say I'm I'm I'm I'm
flirting with the idea of per perhaps
being more uh serious about B border
control if he really wanted to court
Trump voters he would have taken a
strong stance on the board during the
speech uh you know I think that there
are a lot of Democrats who are unhappy
with Biden he does not pull well what is
it 60% think he's too old and so even
though I think it's like 68 it's some
ridiculous M so ultimately RFK is just
needing to be different than Biden and
he is going to do that obviously I mean
other than our scenario where he you
know collaps on stage and knew some
takes over we know the DNC would never
let RFK be the front runner and so the
independent is the best way he can court
court voters at all like Ross perau what
do you think about him James I like RFK
I think he's run a great campaign
especially by saying he's going to uh
focus on the Deep State he's he's his
whole c campaign has been about the Deep
state is unaccountable to the American
people and my number one PRI priority is
going to be fixing these government
agencies like HHS that destroyed the
country in 2020 so I think his campaign
has been great he may be playing to get
more Democrat votes now but I do think
the effect would be to take more
Republicans or at least right leaning
independence why would they vote for why
would a right leaning independent vote
for Kennedy because they see all his
appearances on all these shows which are
overwhelmingly right leaning and he's
he's talking to he's he's speaking to um
I think he's speaking to right leaning
voters he's antix he his whole thing is
opposing the co tyranny uh opposing the
Deep State and the leftwing media hasn't
given given him any Oxygen whereas the
right-wing media has been giving him all
his oxygen but but there are many people
on the left who hated the lockdowns as
well yeah true but you think as many I
don't think as many you're just sure but
like I I don't see that as being strong
enough if if you come out in your
announcement speech celebrating
indigenous people's day I'm not sure the
anti-woke post Liberals are going to be
like that's my guy I saw that and I
cringed are you just saying he's more
likely he's also anti-gun to capture
like the right leaning Centrist because
that's the media he's in so that's who's
getting the eyeballs that's like those
are the people that happen to be seeing
him exactly I think that's what's
fueling his campaign or the right
leaning Centrist kind of the The Joe
Rogan listener crowd is what's fueling
rfk's campaign and the Republican
nominee if Trump wants to win in 2024
the key to Victory is to get that crowd
see I I can see where you're coming from
but he has RFK has steadily gained among
Democrats I mean he came out at like
what 5% he's almost up to 20%
favorability among Democrats now so as
much as maybe there are a couple people
who are excited about him who are sort
of moderate to you know almost
independent Republicans will say uh I
think there are more people who are
discontented in his base that he wielded
pull away the numbers aren't
proportional I think it will hurt
Democrats more than I hope you guys are
right and it'll be interesting to see
what voters RFK targets now and if he
shifts the style of his campaign like
you just said Tim where maybe this is
more a leftward shift he's that's always
been his campaign like it's been
conservatives that have been hooting and
hollering because they like what he said
about Co but they're ignoring everything
else that he said I mean and and a lot
of never would have voted for a lot of
Libertarians have come out and been like
the dude is anti-gun he's like a liberal
who just his only position that aligns
with conservatives is that he didn't
like the co lockdown but he's also been
very critical of woke culture cancel
culture and the far-left and I think the
Republicans like him for that reason too
he's kind of this symbol of you know I'm
a non-woke liberal and Republicans love
to jump on that I just think that there
are lots of moderates who lean left
socially uh that also feel that way I
think we don't give enough credit the
fact that the DNC and the Biden
Administration have to court the middle
ground when they have positioned
themselves Kennedy J more and more
towards the left uh I think that he just
needs to be not establishment to a Biden
DNC I think that the Republicans have
enough on the field where it's unlikely
that they you'll see tons of Republicans
flocking to RFK because you know he
ultimately is an environmentalist lawyer
I mean he's not someone that is going to
capture people on their base I think
what I find most interesting about his
shift towards an being an independent
candidate is what he said which was that
you know it is painful for me to leave
the party that my family's political
Legacy comes from but I think it's so
often that we see the media obviously
for for in my opinion biased reasons
focusing on fractures within the
Republican party that they over they
gloss over uh the splintering that is
going on among Democrats and that's real
it's documented even if the mainstream
media AP News doesn't want to talk about
it and Cornell West who is more leftwing
is now also going to run as independent
mhm so that's definitely taking votes
away from the Democrat according to
ipsos in a three-way race with RFK Jor
and independent you have Biden getting
31 Trump getting 33 and RFK Jr getting
14 without RFK Jr it's a statistical tie
between Biden and Trump so ipsos data
from October 3rd to the 4th shows that
RFK Jr hurts the Democrats wow so and
this is what I this this is what I
thought if you take a look at the graph
you can actually see that there is only
tiny red sliver that jumps to RFK but a
larger portion of the Democrats why
Trump supporters will crawl overo broken
glass to vote for him Democrat voters
think Joe Biden's too old and don't like
him they just don't like
Trump and I mean I was looking at a poll
that came out of New Hampshire a couple
weeks ago you know they'll say who you
planning on voting for and they'll say
who's your second choice candidate and
it's not like Republicans are saying
well if it's if it's not my number one
choice you know disantis Trump whoever
it is I'm going to switch to RFK they're
going to pick another Republican they're
more likely to whereas Democrats are not
particularly happy with Biden already
and so if they're presented an
alternative it's more likely that
they'll pick it yeah like Viv I think
he's a much more favorable candidate to
a republican mindset than to Republicans
but not to Democrats whereas RFK is you
know at least Baseline more Republic
especially to that moderate class that I
think the DNC really overlooks I mean
they trample on them all the time good
point I'm excited about it guys I love
when we have a third party candidate I
mean I will say I listened to this whole
speech um because that's what I do for
my job and uh I like that he talked
about he had this line saying you know
there have been independent candidates
in the past but this time it's going to
be different because you're going to win
and I don't think that's necessarily
true but I do think that it's nice to
see someone who is representing people
who are frustrated with the party system
Teddy Roosevelt won third party yeah he
did take a look at this Kennedy family
members call RFK Junior's independent
bid dangerous to our country to be fair
they were doing that before they really
don't like him Christmas and
Thanksgiving going be super awkward for
the Kennedy family this year yep they
strip boats away from can you imagine
like having Thanksgiving with your
family and you're a former Governor your
brother is a senator your other
brother's running for president and
you're just like you know you shouldn't
be running for president like well I'm
going to it's like guys know politics at
the table Yeah Yeah they H saying his
dad would have them all talk politics
Bobby or like I think his grandpa would
have his dad and his uncle John and and
I mean his speech he's Nam dropping
everybody because they really did have
such a d Y in his life I mean it's not a
joke I just can't imagine you know
working out like hey you're not invited
to Thanksgiving this year because you're
running for president as a third party
candidate they're like cool I didn't
want to go anyways yeah I he's actually
said his family disagrees with him
politically but they get along and he
has a bunch of uh pretty mainstream I
mean not that Hollywood is where you
should put all your your interest but he
has a lot of celebrity followers isn't
it like Woody harelson he had the uh
concert with I can't remember his name
off the top of my head but you know know
RFK has appeal in a way that Biden does
not in a lot of aspects of culture his
wife is super famous actor Cheryl Hines
from just Curb Your Enthusiasm Larry I'm
just going to say it her outfit today
was great I would be happy to have her
come on as a first lady very stylish
what was her outfit she wore this like
white double double breasted uh
button-down suit and it just she looked
classy I can't I can't help it I don't
really want her husband to be president
but I'm happy that he's in the race
we're going to get some great great
moments from her always liked this girl
she's a great actor man she anchored
that show Kirby Your
Enthusiasm and Cheryl his wife is this
it yeah but that's not today's picture
I'll find it oh right yeah I'm trying to
find it you just look up share oh her
dress apparently it's not the thing the
mainstream media wants to report on
That's So Rude of them yeah I know you
know I'm over here you trying to have a
serious news program and let people know
the clothing of I slowly convert IRL to
a fashion review program thank you so
much everybody what do you think Cheryl
looks like it seems like um she has no
political acumen I can't tell for sure
but she seems like she's like a normie
actor like not Normie but she's like
outside the the whole thing do you think
that's good was it this yes oh okay I
mean that's kind of basic it's basic but
it's white it's pretty it's fitted well
she doesn't look overdone she doesn't
like to St too hard I I I I just I don't
get what the argument is as to why Trump
voters would choose Kennedy I just don't
get it look I'm especially because we
got milania I I I I'm in a position
where it's like I've been saying I'm 51%
for Trump he's the best option that we
have I hope he fires people I think his
foreign policy was was the best we've
seen of my lifetime but I think that
they are Character defects of the guy
and it's like obviously there could be
better when I say 51 I'm basically
saying as far as presidents go being a
net positive is a really powerful thing
for me to say but J RFK Jr it's like oh
he's cool like I'm glad he's speaking up
against like the coid lockdown stuff but
I would never vote for the guy how much
I was going to ask you James like how
much of of the president's value and
effectivity is like based is around that
one guy and around how much of it is
around the people he surrounds himself
with well I think it's been a trend in
American politics since FDR of the
presidency becoming more and more
ceremonial over time to the point today
where today's president has a 100 the
power that FDR did uh Curtis yarin has
talked about that a lot um the Deep
state has become a massive problem and
the people truly pulling the levers of
Power are kind of this expert class at
the top of the bureau rcy that of course
leans left and is permanent you know
they have Civil Service
protections and it makes it hard for a
president to control the bureaucracy and
control the policy and it it's not just
for Republicans it's for Democrats too
although the bureaucracy just tends to
agree with them more it's kind of just a
coincidence is that why you got involved
with your project with Heritage yeah
that's the idea behind project 2025 at
Heritage actually which is basically an
effort to get the Personnel right this
next Administration and also an effort
to make sure that the bureaucrats that
have the true levers of power in our
bureaucracy are able to be held
accountable that doesn't mean we're
going to fire all of them but if
somebody is obstructing policy it's
making sure that person can be fired
because you know all these candidates
love to talk about what they're going to
do but if you don't first get the
bureaucracy under control you can't do
anything else so I imagine president's
pretty neutered when it comes to that
but like what with a good staff with a
good like what would be an example like
what are the top three or five roles
that the president would need to
surround him or herself with like what
are the top five powerful roles that
they would pick and put I Know Chief of
Staff would be one of them chief of
staff is extremely important I think I
don't think it's necessarily the roles I
think it's the actions the president
would need to take there is a massive
barrier between the president and his
own cabinet secretaries so there's a
White House bureaucracy within the White
House itself and they kind of serve as
this management barrier where they they
tell the president's cabinet secretaries
what to do instead of the president
directly and this this management
bureaucracy was created under FDR and
it's only grown bigger and bigger so I
think the next president needs to do
things like kick the National Security
Council permanent bureaucrat staff out
of the White House on day one do things
like that you know make sure that your
cabinet secretary are being told by you
solely what to do there's too many
middlemen that the president has so if
you cut down on these layers of
bureaucracy and tell your decision
makers exactly what to do that's that's
kind of the way of managing it and the
other thing is the president needs to
delegate less and follow up more that
that's the key to all of this because
these bureaucrats thrive in the shadows
they don't want to be confronted if if
the president and his cabinet secretar
dig into these agencies they are going
to figure out how things are really run
and they're going to get a better handle
on this stuff why did FDR create this
managerial class why did he put people
in in the middle so FDR was spinning up
all these new agencies in the 30s dur
during the New Deal and he wanted to put
in place a system that would last after
he left so he did this thing where he
got all these Progressive academics to
come up with a plan for how can I um
better better make this administrative
State work and these Progressive
academics base their plan on the
monarchies in Europe which had massive
bureaucracies when when the United
States didn't and FDR took their plan
and he implemented it and so it's this
idea of a permanent expert class an
expert class that keeps the policies
going no matter who the president is
it's the antithesis of democracy was it
because he was getting bribed by like
special interests and it was like favors
or was was it because he couldn't run
the government properly to to win the
world war that he needed to fight uh
what what was his motivation like I
think it's I think it's more IDE I think
it's ideological more than anything else
it's just always been this leftwing idea
that we need government by an expert
class yeah it's like the maneria
revolution of people refer to as so what
are you guys specifically doing to
combat this issue so there's the there's
a lot of things the president can do but
basically all the tools the president
has are in the civil service reform Act
of 1978 which actually was passed by
Congress to help the president better
control the Deep State because it had
become such a problem and it created an
agency called the office of personnel
management and they're supposed to
manage the
bureaucrats but what's happened over
time is that agency that was created got
captured by the bureaucrats themselves
so it's totally captured so you have
have to take back that agency and then
use the legal authorities that that you
have which there are many you know
people know about the schedule F
executive order they're familiar with
that that's one of like 10 things the
president can start to do to hold the
the bureaucracy accountable so you think
going in and firing everyone maybe isn't
is not the right move but to go in and
be very selective about who and what to
remove or do you think more of just a
broad sweeping 75% reduction of
Workforce among the managerial class
what do you think is more effective I
think you need to do uh parts of both so
you need to do reductions in force where
you get rid of these non-essential
workers the non-essential bureaucracy I
like to say there's a deep State at the
top that's the leftwing expert class but
then there's like the DMV state below
them and these are like the millions of
unionized civil service protected
employees it's 2.25 million employees
and the president can only hire and fire
at will 4,000 of them so 99.9% of his
own employees he can't fire so you have
to you know get rid of the non-essential
ones and you can use reduction Force
exercises which is just a fancy term for
Mass government layoffs to do that but
then at the top it's more you know
picking apart um certain places where
the bureaucracy has a hold like the
state department you need to go in and
tear that place apart if people are
resisting you need to fire them um but
there's there's a lot of nuances to it
how would you implement reduction Force
exercises you would look at the parts of
the federal government that are truly
non-essential and it's funny because we
already have a list of these positions
when it when the government shuts down
all the non-essential workers go home
and we have this list that we like are
like you're not even that important
leave exactly exactly and so you're not
going to fire all those people but what
does it being non-essential mean it
means they're non-essential in some way
yeah is there
start from there and look at that is
would it be an executive order that
would be like this would put it into
action or something this this agency uh
office of personnel management would do
it so for example on day one you could
say we're doing a reduction in force to
get rid of all the diversity equity and
inclusion offices across the federal
government and let's just start there I
wish let's just start there I wish dude
it's a good place to start that's how
you got your job Serge right yeah right
that's how I got my job and that's
because you can't fire them individually
you've got to reduce the force somehow
Vivic was get around exactly it gets
around put them all in the Illusions
just be like what Permanent Vacation
enjoy yourself no but I mean get a nice
house one one one thing we can do is use
an opportunity to develop areas that
need development so by putting them in
Alaska we then have to fund the creation
of cities and towns most the people
aren't going to want to be there and so
then what we'll do is we'll just you
know look for oil and things like that
in our own land I think Stalin did that
with Siberia although I don't think the
oil I I don't know if they got treated
very well you pick pick a place that
needs development you know start putting
the offices there what is your concern
with mass layoffs like um I know that in
Iraq when we invaded we disbanded the
bath party and so you can never serve in
government again and they all formed
Isis basically formed terrorist cells
because they're like what else can we do
we have connections in the military yeah
like this vision of like American
bureaucrats who get laid off being like
well now we're going to organize into
I'm not even joking cuz they've got
friends in the military own domestic
terrorism is just laid off yeah they
join antifa Trump wins they get fired
now they're brok and they're angry and
they go become anti recruitment spikes
when we lay them off maybe we shouldn't
lay them off that's a that's a very comp
relocate them first to the utions as
close to Japan as possible what let me
let me pull this up do you think there's
a a risk that that they could form some
sort of radical um like NGO or something
Evolutions are Liberia bureaucrats I
think we do need Mass layoffs for the
record I think we do need Mass layoffs
at two station right here look at this
yeah it's it's out there it's out there
it's hard okay it's closer to Russia so
when you want to go work for the
government you got to think carefully
like you want an essential job because
you are at risk of being shipped
up this little thing right here this is
America yeah it is this is United
States or go away that's that's United
States right there and we can take all
the bureaucrats and just station them
right there and we build it it's wortha
ceremony set it up I don't know about
all that I'm just saying just give talks
just you know then we'll then we'll have
a base right there and you know in the
Bearing Sea is that a military base I I
got to be completely honest though it's
50 degrees there right now at 422 p.m.
and if I was working in a government
office in DC in there like we're sending
you to at two station the Illusions I'd
be like that's awesome I'd be so excited
for that like it's not forever but it
wouldn't it be cool to like be out there
in the middle of kind of but if China
does try and take Taiwan taiwan's not
the only Island they would oh bro
they're not that close to Taiwan they're
safe about look how far away that
is 3,000 miles away people talk about
concern of China invading Taiwan it
wouldn't just be Taiwan that's not the
only Island they would attack they it
would be a lot of islands at once don't
no internet no internet the bureaucrats
will be able to organize and defend
themselves they're going we're sending
we send them all to at two station
there's no internet yes all snail mail
and the plane comes once every other
week yeah it's tough sounds fun I don't
know it's like one of those jobs you
ever see those on the internet where
they're like you can get paid a million
dollars a year to live on this remote
island and maintain its Lighthouse
like no you'll see these things on
occasion you know I look at those jobs
especially if you work and and this is
not to mean to any of our bureaucrats
who are listening and who support the
show you guys are great but if you work
in like a boring office for the
government and you are constantly being
reminded every couple years that you're
non-essential when the government sits
down it's got to hurt your self-esteem
right you would take this cool Island
maintain whatever hang out with the
other guys someone in the chat there
says they left in 2011 it's no longer
been inhabited inhabited since then so
we we got we got to fix it exactly make
at station great again but but look look
at all these islands look at this man
you got on on Alaska Island this is
where they do that crab show or whatever
it's called Fun CCH dead catch that's
right is that what it is much is look
how cool that it's amazing be a cool
posting paid for I got to be honest if I
right you know I'm really sold on this
idea look at this there's a Safeway wow
if there's a Safeway it's got to be
right everything's going to cost like
$40 but it'll be all right there I mean
here's the reality people would love to
like get a trip to go somewhere like
that some exotic location it's pension I
think Charlie Kirk he was pushing to
decentralize the uh just the RNC the
Republican uh convention and so
decentralizing the government might also
be effective so they're not all sitting
there on K Street able to walk from one
guy's office it's funny I actually went
on Charlie Kirk's show to tell him why
that was a bad idea tell me why it kind
of works but it doesn't Africa we have
three different states but the problem
is that the president doesn't control
the government and moving the agencies
away is kind of what the bureaucrats
want they want to be away from his
supervision it gives them more autonomy
dude these employees they could be going
to Amelia right now don't they want to
support local businesses on these
islands are you going to build this into
your plan that this is part of uh
managing it's going to be taken into
consideration here seriously there I'm
not joking they should totally do this
because you then get the uh uh you get
development why why are we wasting money
on these departments doe and all this
stuff no no no no Department of
Education I should say let's just that
funding instead of just pulling the
Band-Aid off and getting this big
Congressional f b okay well we agree
we'll keep funding it but it's got to be
in on Alaska no and then what happens
you start developing this area spreading
people out it expands American interest
it's just really great for us all around
well wasn't this this thing with the
Department of interior you know it got
moved its headquarters were going to be
in Colorado and then Joe Biden was like
no we're going to bring it back to DC
like they just don't want to hang out in
DC and work jobs that are PR
decentralized DC they should go and
let's send them to this fun Island
Amelia can have some customers I got to
be honest I bet you if they said like
100 postings in un Alaska it would be
filled instantly well that's what James
is saying is they want to be away they
want less oversight so when they're in
DC at least the president's able to have
oversight over them and if they're off
but I think this is sort of extreme
right like I think only people who must
really love their jobs or want to be on
this island are going to take a posting
somewhere that remote not to be mean to
aelia's restaurant which I've heard is
great based on I I looked into going
here apparently it's like really hard
cuz like to get in well something about
like the flights are rare yeah because I
mean this is true I've mentioned this
before but my family's from uh New
Finland and like places where there are
establish there there are populations
but people just don't come and go You
Can't Always Get the fery it's not a
drop of a hat right there has to be
traffic there and that's New Finland
Canada which is right above main which
is not as remote as this island just it
would be really cool to go eat at
Amelia's check that out yeah put it on
the on theck List have a Mexican
restaurant this is great culture where's
a Mexican restaurant that's amilio it
says Mexican restaurant underneath does
it really right there oh it does Mexican
restaurant yeah oh I just saw the steak
and I said that looks great wow Mexican
food in un Alaska yeah I'm there that
sounds awesome called on Alaska it's
called the island name of the islands on
Alaska on Alaska that's the name of name
of the town oh yeah right there yeah on
Alaska well there's Church there what is
it Department of uh Parks oh yeah little
parks and W is there W and it's 50°
there right now I really hope we have
not I really hope we have a listener
from un Alaska who's like do not send me
all these bats we already do we
already send the Democrats look at this
they got a gun club based yeah I'm
talking about man I would think that it
there is value to reducing the
bureaucracy because the bureaucracy
would be more willing to work with like
economic Forum um like technocratic
establishment yeah yeah definitely okay
how about this one acatan it's basically
just a seafood Corporation in a post
office they got a playground there in a
public library though a library how many
a great idea yo look at this road house
no delivery though oh that sucks that's
like just anywhere in Rural America
though I I will level with you no Uber
Eats no no no door Dash no dude just I'm
just saying send them all off to the far
reaches of the Earth where they can ever
contact us again
the best part serious if you want to
take a like bureaucrat job like why you
should have to work for it right the job
itself is kind of cushy at least help
this this un underpopulated Island while
you're at it I think part of what we're
going to come up against with mass
layoffs is a lot of these people are
like really good people that work in a
position that should not be there and we
need to and it's like really impersonal
that they're going to lose their job but
like but maybe but they can be offered
early retirement and buy buyouts you can
buy them out you can pay them to leave
exactly also there are all kinds of jobs
out there right like the government jobs
are attractive I get that but there are
other Industries if people need jobs
then they were willing to work which
means that we can have more private
sector growth I don't understand why we
would be like but they work for the
government so they should get to keep
their government job no we should have
other jobs in other sectors that would
be better we should cover their salary
for a whole year and say Hey you know
your dream of being a painter go do that
now yep yep on un Alaska yeah
yeah even better even better I would be
open to that would that bankrupt the
country if we paid their salary for a
year I don't know I don't think it would
be that expensive actually no it would
not be the fact it' be less expensive to
go Sal for you than keep the Ukraine Aid
could pay for that 20 times over couple
times yeah dude okay that's good there's
also uh UT kakik I say it UT kakik I
believe you I think that's how you say
it it used to be called Barrow but then
they renamed it to the indigenous name
or whatever I see that's the
northernmost City yeah bar everybody got
to go there I had a friend who worked in
Alaska doing uh some show I forgot what
reality show it was but there was a
point in the win of Alaska no it was
like ice road truck or something but
there's a point where the snow shuts
down the roads and you're there for the
winter nothing in nothing out and the
internet's all dial up that's wild lines
yeah they got starlink now I I I think
yeah they might yeah and it's it's
become affordable but uh this is only a
few years ago it was like they were
still going to Blockbuster
yeah and and red box was huge it's like
you got to go to the red box and get
like 10 movies well West Virginia was
the one of the places I finally saw
video stores again and it was because
there's not great internet connection
everywhere and you got people who will
you know come into town for the week or
every two weeks to get groceries and
stuff and rent their movies and then go
back on the mountain where there's no
internet service so they need their DVD
player and then come back and like I can
only imagine that's tenfold in certain
parts of Alaska you know elon's taking
away all the mystery I gotta say you
know life was was so much more fun not
you guys remember not knowing you guys
remember not knowing yeah I do thought
about today you less so me every day
don't worry about it no I mean like when
I was a kid there was a period where
it's like I'm going to I call my friend
and he doesn't answer so I go to knock
on the door he doesn't answer I'm like
oh that's it Rock in his window
you and then you just leave and then you
go do something else and you have no
idea what happened this is one of the
problems to talk about with with kids
today and I think you know I I feel like
I transitioned out of this period
because the internet became so dominant
while I was in high school or you know
social media and stuff uh kids today
like if there's if there's fighting at
school if there's like bullying or
whatever else like it just follows you
online after school whereas you don't go
home and if there were drama in the 90s
you just had to call your friends on the
landline whereas now it's it's all over
Snapchat it's all over Instagram you
know there they're sort of plugged into
these scenarios which at times can be
really negative constantly uh maybe it's
nice and that's why people like living
in rural areas where you can say I'm
just going to back away now and I don't
have internet so you can't contact me
that's actually the indoctrination
aspect is like a big part of why I would
not want to public school my kids but
it's that it's that wait what were you
just saying that kids have access to
things online all the time and so
therefore you know inter friend group
drama or whatever it is I couldn't do it
I couldn't put my kid through that like
I had to deal with it in school and then
i' go home and cry and then that would
be it but I didn't have to it didn't
taint my life I mean I think that's
keeping your kids off social media which
is really challenging because there's
that idea that they want to I mean it's
it's it's it's I got an idea are they
going to go to Alaska yes if your being
bullied you can make it all go away by
sending them to unalaska you send your
kid or you move your family or do you
send the bully toas just all of them no
dude I feel like going on a trip there
would be awesome wouldn't you guys want
a vacation like that I don't say they go
there forever you go there for a little
bitting I know I don't want to be on a
Pacific island when we're wondering if
China's going to invade Taiwan not right
now okay well you know what about bats
and Bullies onka I was been thinking
lately I don't want to be I want to go
to Israel but like the last year I've
been thinking I do not want to go there
right now and I guess this is why all
right how about this one
Alfred I was looking I thought you're
going to pull up like a was it cian or
whatever island in the middle of nowhere
I mean this is an island in the middle
of no oh the island that's further from
all other Island look at this one French
Southern Antarctic lands there we go you
just come on down speak French for what
re reason is is it look at all that
light blue that was all above the water
before the flood Before the Flood look
at look it even Google Maps say the ice
wall see yeah this this Pro is it's
proving right now ice wall did you guys
ever look at the expanding Earth
theory the Earth was small and then it
slowly Twisted open you can see how
South America like fits perfectly into
into uh Africa there just pulled open
yeah Pangia and all that P that was the
idea was that it was it was a piece of
land on a big floating ball of water but
the other theory is that it was all rock
and it twisted open and the and the
hydrogen shot out of the cracks and
mixed with the oxygen to form ocean
water how deliciously we're going to go
to super chats everybody if you haven't
already would you kindly smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends and head over
to Tim cast.com click join us become a
member because we're going to have that
members only uncensored show coming up
in about 25 minutes where you as members
can call in and submit questions to us
actually talk on the show and uh you'll
have to join the Discord server where
our timcast members are doing awesome
stuff running their own pre-shows and
after shows making music and other cool
things so definitely check that out but
for now will read your super chats for
which there are many wonder who got
first today waffle Sensei hey shout out
waffles he says as far as intervention
goes I will say that if American
citizens are being held hostage then we
have a duty to destroy the individuals
responsible that's a tough question when
Biden comes out and says that American
citizens are possibly among the hostages
I'm kind of like I don't believe you
you're a liar yeah you can't trust Joe
Biden I mean and also there are
Americans who are wrongfully detained in
Russia right like got Americans all over
the place that we need to to help it's
it's not to downplay the suffering that
they might be going through but we got
to got to think this one out it
certainly speaks of the danger of not
trusting your government because when
the hits the fan for real and you
don't trust him that's a big problem
yeah what's next Joseph says no
intervention equals I'm okay with
suffering LOL I mean like the problem
with intervention is we can't intervene
everywhere so then it's just someone is
like I watched the news today and this
country was was bad so we must intervene
it's like did you watch news yesterday
other country was bad which one do you
want to intervene in you can't do all of
them current thing thing could you
imagine like I don't know I just think
about things domestically like you you
you hear fighting down the street from
your neighbor's house and you're like
I'm going to have to intervene and so
you and your buddies go down to that
house and like kick the door and and go
in and say everybody on the ground you
know like no you call the police I guess
there there's like a you know a force
that can deal with that I don't know if
there's no there's no International
force or whatever but like imagine that
you know there's there's a house down
the street from you in the room roomates
are having a dispute over who gets to
use like the game room at what time and
they're fighting you're just going to be
like bro I have nothing to do with this
also in a different house someone else
is yelling and you're like not that
house that one's not that one's not
suffering yeah right no but like there's
one house and you hear two guys arguing
with the game room and they're fighting
and you're like that fighting is getting
pretty bad maybe I should go kick the
door in then there's another house next
door where you hear a woman mercilessly
SC like scream mercilessly being beaten
and she's screaming for help please dear
Lord help me and you're like and there's
a Russian guy with a big gun standing
goes no and you're like yeah okay no
intervention there like it's just yeah
how about we just be like look man I
guess the domestic analy doesn't really
work because you can always call the
cops there is some
interhome you know law enforcement
agency yeah I guess you can call Team
America right team America man The A
Team Greg duvier says I find it
interesting that General Mark Millie
retires a few days before the attack on
Israel just a thought I had I doubt
there is any connection just an
interesting coincidence that came to
mind yeah but it might not be only one
holding it together mhm it was him
personally with him gone all right
that's when Israel Hamas was like you
know what we've got we've got to roll
in federali actual says thank you for a
good 12th maybe of Riding High on white
pills three of the best journalists of
my generation talking shop on the
culture war and then an amazing event no
comment on how awful this world is keep
your heads up that's right Friday
morning in the culture War it was me
Lukowski and James O'Keefe that was a
really amazing conversation we we didn't
really talk about JM we talked about
people being evil getting older and
realizing that some people's intentions
are just malicious and what it means to
be backstabbed and this is obviously
because project Veritas stabbed James
o'keef in the back brutal stuff yeah
I've been thinking that a lot how weird
it is when people lie like and they but
they like they like it they get their
they twist their minds into now enjoying
lying that's that's weird dude it's like
I I I talk about how people always say
it's hard to play the evil route in
video games like they they you know RPGs
that allow you to play the good guy or
the bad guy and everyone always jokes
it's it's hard to play the bad guy and
I'm like nah they make it for a reason
yeah there are people who just like
being evil it's weird I can't understand
it it's weird but I've certainly
experienced evil people man people who
gloat and laugh about conflict crisis
they're demons they just want the
suffering crazy and they'll sometimes
they'll lie because they think they're
doing good with it and maybe maybe maybe
they are that's still different I'm not
talking about people who think they're
good who do bad things I'm the ones that
are enjoying it they're like tricking
them and I like it like I'm telling you
there was a person that occupied Wall
Street who said they just wanted to
watch the world burn it it was fun don't
you want to just shake it all up and
watch it burn and I'm like no what that
was the mentality of of some of these
people yeah Shane H Wilder says not to
downplay the situation which probably
would not have happened if Trump was in
office but how long until we're in hot
war no wartime president has ever lost
so this could be used to bolster Biden's
numbers I do not think so yeah I don't
uh n i mean i get it but Biden is not a
wartime President Biden is an a resident
of the White House during war there's a
difference yeah he he's he's just not
Lucid no wartime president is lost
because they get up on stage and they
say the American people will not stand
and then everyone it's like they're all
screaming and cheering Biden's going to
be like Y come on
man they B they're bombing Lebanon and
like no it's Israel that got attacked
like what what Libya they like oh jeez
whatever well Biden just sort of makes
things up WR so we're pretending that
we're not as involved in a lot of wars
that we are obviously involved in right
I don't think he's a wartime president
but he is also not successfully handling
any of the conflict he's gotten us
entangled yeah if he's a wartime
president he really messed up that
Afghanistan situation the emperor's
Champion says I have completely lost any
sympathy I had for the Palestinians and
I don't believe anything the left says
about Israel because of how much they
lie yeah but it's not it's not all
Palestinians it's it's really this this
militant
group no bro bro you can't have every
prominent speaker be like yay we did it
and then when you're like whoa you guys
align with Hamas no no they're a
military group and then they'll look at
each other and give them like dude I I
suppose those celebrating hamas's moves
would be in support of Hamas imagine
imagine just
like okay obviously we as American
citizens are are are not happy with
what's happening in Ukraine but you
better believe they're taking your tax
dollars and using it to fund them war in
Ukraine I wrote this on Twitter
ignorantly supporting something doesn't
make you an advocate for it but history
might not know the difference however
Russia wanting the us to stop its NATO
expansionist policies is not going to
differentiate between any of us they're
going to be like the United States is
the Machine by which we are being
attacked I guess that's why you don't
kill civilians and Putin specifically
was like yeah yeah yeah we won't do
anything if you promise not to expand
NATO and Joe Biden was like can't can't
promise that so where was our compromise
then and that's the point when Hamas
goes and just starts kidnapping and
killing civilians and threatening to
kill more you know who the bad guys are
I'm not saying Israel is good I'm not
saying the war the anything was good and
you know Everyone likes what's happening
I'm saying one side let's put it this
way let's say Israel is just better at
propaganda and they're like when we do
it we'll make sure we're doing it smart
okay well then the public face of all of
this is Israel is trying to avoid
civilian deaths but still collateral
damage happens and civilians die and
Hamas is gloating and threatening to
kill more yeah dude I was thinking why
are they showing video of these
atrocities that they're committing like
Israel at least if they're going to do
it they seem to do it under the radar
and it's like is it just their desire to
be known to be relevant supersedes even
that the desire to hide their evil Deeds
why do you record your songs and play
them like why why do you I want to show
people yeah why are you proud of it yeah
yeah isn't that wild like people just
want to be relevant they want to be seen
it's not about relevant it's about them
these people in New York are cheering
for what happened yeah they're they're
clapping and hooting and cheering the
people in in Hamas who are doing this
want to show those videos to those
people so they cheer for them
exactly God man some of it's so brutal
I've only seen a few ofil people want to
seek praise from other evil people a guy
said he saw a video of a girl on fire
did you guys see that video I wouldn't
doubt it I'm sure and like for a long
time until she died yeah yeah takes a
while I mean there's a reason they were
like we're going to execute people on TV
right y That's why Isis had like the
best media team ever so there a reason
for that they hung out on Twitter for a
really long time from what I remember
yeah mhm C Warriors say Ian I am
constantly impressed with your
willingness to be open and vulnerable
your body is your temple to God and when
you honor it you open your doors to him
thank you I'm telling you Ian started
working out now he's praying to Jesus
it's true I prayed to Jesus ear right on
the right rightwing uh extremist
pipeline like right that's cool you can
pray to your father your mother your
sister you can pray to anyone and you'll
hear their voice talk back to you well
at least for my experience it seems to
work not we not I don't think you're
praying to them but I understand it's
like God speaks to you through the VIS
of what you pray to too you can say that
sure yeah Ian starts working out look
what's going on oh I worked out today
see I'm tell you guys hell yeah good job
man good so much all right Andrew Roland
says what everyone is forgetting is that
Hamas attacked civilians not an army
base oh so this is my ARG once you
directly go for the civilians all gloves
are off when the counterargument that
you're going to get with that argument
and you're right they did but is that
Israel has been sieging civilians and
starving them and having them live
without medicine so it's like a a
passive attack on
civilians
um I'm G to sure I follow that's the
argument that the Palestinians are
making is that Israel has been passively
attacking the civilians by putting them
in a Siege situation the conditions in
Gaza are are are brutal and it's very
very bad yeah Israel controls a lot of
what goes into and out of the Gaza Strip
there's also a border with Egypt the
Gaza Strip borders Egypt what is it the
Rafa cross which which Crossing is that
yeah I think so it's not just Israel not
just is fault why is in Egypt opening
the borders and helping people yeah why
is Egypt doing this egpt was actually
flooding the tunnels under Gaza why
would egpt poisonous gas down there why
why Ian why is Egypt starving the people
of Gaz because they work for us man they
work for the liberal economic order they
don't want they don't want to spread the
the anger everyone keeps saying Israel
but they forgot there's another border
here right well Egypt told uh Israel
something big was happening remember
that report that's right and that's
supposed to make paint Israel in a bad
life weirdly the country that moderates
between the two had this information
apparently I mean it all just seems like
you know I don't want to say anything
that I don't know about but it seems
like obviously there is Nuance to this
conflict that none of us pay attention
or it's difficult for people who are not
there to know all the details of number
one American Rob says Ian is correct 911
was the start I can't believe I just
said Ian is correct it really is the end
it's just the beginning
man oh man Gary Wilson says how did the
DSA node have a rally the day after the
attack it takes weeks to permit I want
all members to question including the
squad and begin the expulsion of the
squad for their support of the attack um
organizing these rallies is a day of
thing in New York everyone just hops on
the train and meets up in Time Square
when the DSA put out a tweet that was it
the event was organized and they don't
need permits for it because it's free
speech uh that being said I believe it
is entirely Justified okay AOC needs to
answer for that video what does that
mean I'm not saying disavow I'm saying a
journalist should ask AOC you AOC are a
card caring member of the Democratic
Socialist of America who promoted an
event where they celebrated the murder
of civilians do you agree with your
organiz
or is this an instance where your
opinion stands out and I will say it to
me from checking your Twitter I haven't
seen any statements come out about any
of this so it seems like her office is
going
dark how hard is it to be like K
civilians I bet there are journalists
that are trying to get a hold of her and
she is stealthily avoiding this which is
not a great sign you know well I just
think it's it is it I'm just going to
I'm just going to come out and say it
AOC has not issued a statement
condemning an organization she's a
member of celebr elting the the mass
killing of Jews when did she hasn't even
posted on Twitter in like 3 days right
wow she went dark I mean like you can't
come out and condemn violence I thought
what yeah I think it's because she knows
that her base is a bunch of people who
hate Israel and hate hate Jewish yep yep
for real and I think you'll see this
throughout the Democratic party there is
going to be a lot of people who are now
uh losing support because there is
probably no correct way they could make
everyone happy can we just imagine like
a politician who is a known member of
the clan and the clan goes out
celebrating the lynching of of a black
guy and then people are like well you
know AOC like the the the the polian
didn't know about like dude she's a
member of that organization proudly
proudly Affiliated they're celebrating
the death of civilians and she goes dark
yeah I think she supports it yep I think
it is fair to say right now okazi ctez
supports what happened with Hamas coming
and killing civilians but it might also
be like if she did speak out against it
that her base would Revolt that's a good
point speaks out against
against she supporting her constituents
yeah in action is an action I mean and
in this regard what I'm saying is she
doesn't want to cause damage to the
people she supports exactly that's
interesting too because she's supposed
to be a representative of the people she
represents so if they want war does that
mean she has to want war is that she no
represent supposed to be the Safeguard
for that she should come out and condemn
the killing of civilians but she knows
she will get eviscerated by the left so
she says nothing cuz she's evil mhm I
think it's funny though that the
Democrats that are condemning her are
staunch interventionists and they're
like what what a horrible thing for this
squad to say send our troops over to
Israel and send more money it's like oh
jeez I saw that Mike C one the other huh
that Mike cernovich tweet about people
that were so much about pro-life life in
the womb he's like if a baby dies in the
womb in Gaza is that an abortion yeah St
is great he's a smart guy that's that's
a good point right I'm not I I think the
the the problem is we're dealing with
war yeah Israel is going to respond the
alasan brigades use civilian uh uh
locations Hospital schools Etc or if
they have hospitals intentionally and
then Israel's only choice is either you
take out where the Rockets are coming
from or you let them keep firing rockets
at you if if Israel did not have the
Iron Dome The Narrative would be very
very different mhm The Narrative would
be every day another another Israeli was
being killed killed killed killed killed
and it would not be the same for the
people of of Palestine of Gaza but
because they have the Iron Dome this is
the craziest thing antifa beats people
consistently but because they're not
killing them because these people are
you know more likely to survive or
whatever it doesn't make the news that's
like the issue because Israel is able to
stop the Rockets people act like
Israel's fine MH I like bro I mean if
they didn't have the Iron Dome narrative
would be very different it's crazy isn't
it we need a graphine dome someone wrote
it in the chat right when I said it Mark
Johnson what's up dude that's awesome
right after I said it it appeared the
the Iron Dome is just when a Rocket's
fired another rocket blows it up yeah
yeah they cost I think they said 20
times more each Israeli rocket cost 20
times as much as each Palestinian rocket
it's blowing up and the Palestinians are
just firing a bunch of rockets at random
hoping to hit as many civilians as
possible yeah and they do they're
targeting civilians that's why they
cheered that the Rockets reached Tel
Aviv that's crazy in what circumstance H
have we ever as a nation in war been
like yeah we bombed a bunch of civilians
it's it's not happening we've never been
the under well I don't know I never the
American Revolution we're kind of an
underdog yeah but the underdog when
you're like I would imagine if you're
like oppressed and you're in complete
and total slave servitude like you'll do
whatever you can to get out anything I
don't see
how killing
civilians helps anyone in that
circumstance like I was saying if you're
in if you're in prison and you break out
and the first thing you do is run full
speed mercilessly Beat to Death a
20-year-old woman it's going to
everyone's going to be like clearly
Freedom wasn't a first priority MH like
the argument is that these barriers in
these fences are keeping them in prison
so they're breaking out yeah aler put up
that video where they're like these
these these fences are not borders and
they're can they're they're kept in
there with no resources or whatever so
when they return they're tearing these
barricades down and I'm like yeah and
then they're running full speed just
going in murdering civilians it doesn't
help their case exactly you're not yeah
if if if they broke out and like I said
targeted only military and and and
ushered away imagine if they tore the
barricades down parag glided in told
rounded up all the civilians and then
said start leaving get in your cars and
go go go go go no no no no no we don't
want we don't we don't want you guys
getting C caught in this and then
actually the militants seized the
territory and held it very different and
then issued a declaration that this land
is historically Palestine and was seized
by illegally by Israel they've evacuated
the civilians but are claiming this
territory what would the narrative been
then it would have been a very very
different narrative still war still
conflict gunfight probably would have
still happened but we would be sitting
there being like why are they killing
civilians I was reading that uh in
Israel that a lot of them are disarmed
they don't have guns and a big part of
the problem right now is that Hamas knew
that that's why they were going door to
door slowly just executing people and
then the Israeli government issued like
an emergency order to give people the
right to get guns really really rapidly
I can't believe that Israel had gun
control like this crazy dude it's a war
zone absolute necessity for a second
amendment for right to bear arms that is
why I think one of the things about
Hamas too is how can they say they
represent people in palestin when
they're will to put them In Harm's Way
knowingly put them In Harm's Way and put
those those uh surface air missiles Etc
on their in their hospitals how can you
say represent Palestinians you're
willing to get them killed they say they
got nothing left to lose yeah I mean I
guess all the people you're fighting for
you don't mind if they all die I don't
know about that that that's where my
where I draw the line I all right MCM
Morris says to Ian the holy spirit is
with you don't be afraid be glad let the
Holy Spirit work inside trust the word I
recommend you read the New Testament
book one John it's a short read God
bless thanks yeah my plan is to read the
Bible the Torah and the Quran yeah I
gave him the old the Quran maybe I gave
the talmud and the Torah as well right
yeah yeah that's John 1 I think he said
John one oh I was reading The Sermon on
the Mount dud what's but Al also the
what Hadith is that it Hadith are like
additions to the Quran the Quran is the
main book but if you want to understand
a lot of what we're seeing in mod you
got to read that the Hadith there are
many of them um Red by Islamic scholars
who have studied the Quran who said that
they have like some sort of connection
to allow them to write more about it but
yeah the talmud is like the from what I
understand the other book like the
Hadith in a sense it's addition to like
the main book like the footnotes for
dummies sure the Torah for Dummies and
thean other reading additional reading
yeah does the Bible have anything like
that I mean not really Old Testament New
Testament yeah all right Monk and
training says Tim us supports Israel
because it's a cultural technological
intelligence Ally Ian what are you uh
what is that Ian one what are you seeing
now the results of a culture at war with
the West at large and is Israel peace
can't be held when you have enemies that
want you dead I don't understand the
question exactly I don't think there a
question I think he's saying you can't
have peace if your other the other side
wants you dead like if there's two
people and one guy's like look man can
we just leave each other alone the other
side the other guy is saying like no I
want death in the United States that's
why you carry a weapon and so the left
makes the argument which they're lying
where they show the comic where it's the
clan and a bunch of black people and a
guy in the middle saying compromise
which is literally not the argument
between left and right left and right is
saying destroy the right there evil and
there fascists and the right saying
please leave me alone you know why
because I believe deep down most of the
anger and aggression is about territory
that the United States has invaded Iraq
invaded Afghanistan Libya um and that
Israel was formed in 1918 or whenever it
was formed and put there so like I don't
think they hate just hate me I think
that they hate that we've colonized that
area of the world and displaced them Mr
abvious says the amount of people
justifying war crimes right now is
astounding the same people who said
Russia was evil for bombing schools and
hospitals are saying it's fine when
Israel bombs civilian centers I think
it's all bad I just want the violence to
end and here's my response is you are
completely correct about bombing schools
and hospitals but they're not
arbitrarily doing it Israel was not like
ha we're going to go BL up a hospital
they were like hey all those Rockets are
being fired from a hospital what do we
do well take it out that's where the
Rockets are coming from yep I want to
give a shout out to Shu on head however
who tweeted as an American I frankly
couldn't imagine having my water shut
off every time my country did a war
crime
yeah wow it's a really great tweet
because it acknowledges that it was a
war crime what Hamas did but the US
would be in real trouble if we kept
getting our water shut off every time we
did something true that that's
great where are we at let's see Patriot
American says Hannah the IRA he means
Hannah Clair the IRA used to have
backing from politicians even judges of
Irish Catholic descent in America dating
back to the Irish war of independence in
1918 up until the end of the troubles in
Northern Ireland in 1995 oh I forgot
that we put boots on the grounds then we
didn't though I mean it's one thing for
there to be support politically but we
didn't intervene in the way that we were
obviously going to in Israel I just love
how the uh like you have this the
troubles you know 30 years ago in
Ireland and they're like Ireland for the
Irish uh but now they're all like
globalists who are like open borders and
like what it's funny how this conflict
only ended because of the European Union
cre created the shenen zone so now
there's like yeah it was weird but now
that's all done again I guess cuz of
brexit yeah true
weird case Clos says Tim it was cool
singing in Miami last week the next day
was also cool because I visited the Bay
of Pigs Museum and met a veteran of the
invasion who actually knew Mr R time
arem how do you say that namesake of the
theater I don't know R te probably yeah
AR te wow that's very cool very cool
yeah Miami was fun we're thinking
Nashville for the next one sounds great
cuz we were talking about Nashville for
a while yeah base records is there da
wires there right I'm lobbying for
Pittsburgh I've been a huge fan of the
city I've never been why Pittsburgh oh I
like Pittsburgh because two hours away
it's no no no I you know we can travel
but I I like Pittsburgh because it's
this uh industrial city in a a swing
state that's gone through kind of all
the changes with America you know the
Hines catcher museum is there because
that was sort of this political
industrial Dynasty uh and you know we
should do it thank you I think the thing
is the thing about Pittsburgh that's
really easy for us is I think it's
actually like 2 hours 45 minutes from us
CL which means when we did Miami we have
to deploy the mobile Studio they're
still not back what's up they're still
not back no they're still driving are
they okay like they're fine they're just
driving but uh uh if we do Pittsburgh
it's literally we we we just drive up
yeah yeah Friday afternoon we drive up
to Pittsburgh and do the show and it's
substantially easier than doing these uh
trips that are further out it's great
yeah I mean I think Pittsburgh is a
really interesting City I will say I've
never been there I've just read a lot
about it because keep thinking I will go
there uh but it's to me a representation
of a lot of cities in America that get
left behind and I know that there's an
argument to being like Oh we should
bring our show to places that are more
liberal centered but I think especially
because Pennsylvania is such an
interesting place generally I I'm all
for Pittsburgh and you know then we all
go to the hind catcher Museum or we go
to the um is it it's not a PA boy right
I think so uh I always think he's
Maryland but I could be wrong oh yeah
he's Philly yeah um we got to have him
come down yeah we can go look at these
old beautiful Victorian mansions that
were built up during the IND area of of
America we can talk about where the
manufacturing jobs went uh there's this
this hotel that's in an old Monastery
that I would personally like to see come
on Pittsburgh is cool guys well no I
think we can do Pittsburgh within a
couple months because we can we it's
it's it's what it's a drive we do the
show like normal then Friday night we
drive up yeah the the biggest challenge
it's near WVU it's really close so it'd
be cool to like sort of figure out a way
to our West Virginia crew the Nashville
thing is going to be another deploy the
mobile crew a week in Nashville these
are Big trips they're really hard to
pull off takes a really long time uh I
think if we do Pittsburgh we could get
it done in like four or five months
preparation for it not to make our
events team immediately jump into action
but bro people don't understand how hard
it is we're we're uh so for the Miami
event we are slightly above Break Even
across the board this this means
basically like the only money I think we
made was merch and it was a couple Grand
the the event is it cost six figures to
operate to to to do everything we need
to do to make it work and in the end we
uh we like yay we did it we made a good
amount of money and I'm like and that
money goes towards setting up the next
event M cuz if we if we if we call it
here and say Here's the money we got
it's like okay well like we didn't make
enough yeah I think it'd be cool I mean
I don't have anything to do with the
events I'm really grateful of people
that do they work really hard but it
would be interesting if we kind of do a
home in a away format where we do like
you know two hour and two three hour
drive from from us do that radius and
then have the bigger trips too cuz like
uh DC would be really easy DC would be
really easy uh do I mean honestly we go
to Richmond although Richmond's kind of
a host place we go to Cleveland hang out
in Ohio obviously Pittsburgh is number
one in my heart we have to go there
first because I don't know I think part
of it was when I moved to West Virginia
it was like during the pandemic and so
there wasn't a ton of things to do so I
kept thinking when things get open or
whatever else I'll go and uh I honestly
the anthropology home Outlet is near
Pittsburgh and so in my mind I was like
I'll go there and then I'll I wouldn't
do Philly though just personal Reon I
wouldn't do Philly and I wouldn't do
Baltimore to be honest but there are
other places in Virginia uh in West
Virginia you again Pennsylvania I'm g g
to pitch Pittsburgh Pitt a good idea
yeah yeah uh Nancy had mentioned it to
us about a I've been lobbying Nancy for
couple months on it I'd love to do akan
Ohio my hometown no I agree I think we
should I think we should um and it would
be awesome we get VI cuz he's from Ohio
event there y they got Blossom Blossom
Music Center it's an out RFK come to our
Pittsburgh event since apparently he
loves Pennsylvania all right we'll grab
one more Super Chat here we got Luke
wadu says Ian as soon as I heard you say
Jesus told me to tell you and God told
me to respond here's to my my first
Super Chat very well spent I hope you
grow to know and love God I know the god
of love the god of Joy the God of Peace
the god of Hope would love to talk I'm
I'm just saying you know Ian starts
working out and he's he's we we said he
was going to be conservative he to go
far the prayer was I visualized I said g
Jesus please help me and it was a voice
like tell them and so I just thought
okay I'll tell you that that's that I
asked him I guess that's what I got out
maybe if my head was clear there would
have been a longer message the the
pineal gland is decalcifying in the in
the the energy is being beamed into you
Ian I I try to keep asking them things
and it's like it starts to get like um
all this uh what do they call it like uh
things are interference there start to
be interference so you got to kind of
one question at a time relax let your
brain calm down after the message comes
because when you're in calm state is
when you can really hear the message all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel head over to
timcast.net uh you can follow the show
at timcast IRL you can follow me
personally at timcast James you want to
shout anything out I don't uh except
project 2025 if you want to sign up to
serve in the next conservative
Administration go to Project 202.org
right on that's awesome uh I'm Hannah CL
brimo I'm a writer for
timcast.net and on Instagram if you want
to follow me personally I'm on Instagram
at hanac C.B and on X I was about to say
Twitter at HC guys thank you so much and
thanks to everyone who came out to Mii
Miami event it was so fun oh my gosh and
thanks to the road crew Brian Carter who
else was out there Sarah Chris everybody
we got uh Andrew M is on the road
Andrew's not on the road he did he he
went down there though oh he didn't go
down Andrew you just kidding um and a
message for everyone else Allah Hashim I
pray for the god that they give goodness
to the people that need it the things
that they need that they come together
and they start to see each other for
what they are that they're all human on
earth together and that we're doing this
together and that we work
together and I'll see you guys
tomorrow yeah uh shout out to Carter and
Brian and the rest of Ro clue including
Chris and Sarah I think are also on the
way back um it was fun to be in Miami
I'm sorry I didn't see anybody I know a
bunch of people mess me about not being
at the event but when you're there work
in the morning you want to go home and
change clothes cuz you're sweating it's
Miami sometimes you got to I'm going to
make calls so wasn't pretty enough for
you guys got boat sorry about that yeah
that was wonderful all right everybody
uh we'll see you all over at timcast.net
thanks for hanging
out